there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock well hey it's us again and
this episode 165 what's on the docket
we're doing like I said another variety
show because it's the month of October
our favorite month of the year so we're
gonna do several cases on here these are
all I kind of got the idea for this
because I liked so many of the like
poisoner murders from last time kind of
the old timey ones cuz I love old timey
[ __ ] yeah I'm breaking the show up I
think is better it's like it goes faster
if you ask me yeah that's very one
subject we won't always do this but when
appropriate we'll do it yeah but so I
wanted to do four different cases of
famous well not so famous kind of maybe
lesser-known 19th century murders a lot
of which kind of got overshadowed
because of the whole Jack the Ripper
thing but you know there were a lot of
other murders going on in that area at
the same time like of London there were
also some in Austin that were kind of
similar and like some people have even
made parallels between the two saying
there's possible that it could have been
the same guy so we'll kind of get into
that a little bit we're doing four
different cases we're doing of the
Thames torso murders the servant girl
Annihilator yeah yeah and the Denver
strangler who is almost impossible to
find [ __ ] information I don't know
them
and Alfred Knapp who is kind of like
associated with the Denver strangler
days I think but I remember the torso of
the servant girl Annihilator I mean what
a great [ __ ] name that'd be one before
they wouldn't name serial killer that
nowadays well no one really got that
somebody um the writer very famous short
story writer oh Henry he actually called
the killer that in a letter to his
friend and it kind of just like took off
they didn't the media didn't call him
that at the time yeah you know I mean
yeah so we'll be doing that show I'm
drinking mojito tonight Jenny's guy
screwdriver made that for
other than that would be the same I had
to cut back on kugel Khan it's just very
sugary and it's really I think it was
put weight on me I wonder how many
calories right now a gigantic thing
thousands probably thousands and you
would sometimes drink two or three of
them yeah like get off the show and then
we watch movies in there tequila tequila
though yeah yeah I don't like we
actually went to that concert and I had
that damn tequila drink there that ever
it was it was Sauza 2002 kilo and Red
Bull and something else yeah what else
was in there some kind of juice they
called it tropical tequila Mike just had
a little bit of sour in it yeah it was
good though man I'm trying to make that
that was actually a cool little place I
never been there before we actually went
somewhere that last weekend hmm we went
to Tampa to the Absolution festival
which is a two-day festival of like goth
darkwave kind of bands um I posted some
behind that behind behind the scenes
[ __ ] me and jenni and got some a starry
night I posted a couple videos I was
back there and this was another screen
here this was another band that we saw
there and you had actually heard them on
new retro wave that yeah sure way of
that channel yeah they got a song some
about take it it was it take a trip to
the moon or something yeah it sounds
like kind of like old Tears for Fears I
[ __ ] love that band you guys need to
try that check that band out I was
talking to them and super nice guy yeah
super nice and oh we bought that shirt I
wanted to buy another one but they
didn't have one of my size and I always
wanted a CD and they were out yeah it's
got on the net they were out of CDs it's
got um wings on the back silver yes
laying angel wings with a rose and [ __ ]
but if you like Tears for Fears and like
a new retro wave type stuff if you
looked at band up I like that BAM what's
going to coating acorrea
Corinna Corinna Corinna Corinna with EEE
yeah it just kept hearing of all time
and I was watching Mike these guys are
pretty good and I don't sudden they play
and they play that scene on stage and
Isis that
original and yeah it's all original and
I was just saying man that that one song
do you played about trip to the moon and
[ __ ] [ __ ] I love that song
yeah yeah Rob I to buy you [ __ ] so I
started buying some stuff from that I
wanted to make sure it's for them you
know cuz I mean I make sure it's you
know sad well we made the shirts for the
absolution festival which it sounds like
the event yeah do all the screen print
and then she does all the graphic design
and I hit him up says Matt like to make
sure for you guys but they weren't local
they're from like Cincinnati or
something yeah they got a really lot of
bands so I'm like really impressed cuz I
guess they're gonna make this like a
yearly thing now they're gonna do it
every October and this was like the the
main one now we did it started on Friday
we didn't go on Friday but we went on
Saturday and we got there like what six
or seven o'clock in the evening and
there was like a [ __ ] ton of bands it
was like a starry night sleeping pills a
panic priest it wasn't even pills I
thought that the one that I was looking
at was sleeping pills it wasn't sleeping
pills yeah that's what I can remember
what we're called twin tribes oh yeah
they're really good really got bad yeah
I liked him but yeah we saw it was like
a really lot of great bands that's or
maybe there was one there was one but it
wasn't the one I was thinking of yeah
twin tribes yeah but they had I think
they even had like before we got there
they had like a little pre-party and
they had like a little market like with
a lot of different you know people that
had own stuff to sell and everything
like gothy type things it was in Ybor
City in which is the old part of Tampa
in case you didn't you know and I think
the Friday night was at crowbar and then
the Saturday night was it that we went
to was that the Orpheum and that was
like a good that's a cool place but yeah
I hope they do do it every year because
I was like super fun we don't know you
know Tampa's kind of like a long drive
for us I think it took what it took
almost two hours it's about a two-hour
drive but you know we hadn't been in a
long time and it was super fun so you
know if anybody if anybody's in the
Tampa area next October you might want
to check it out if they do it again
because yeah yeah cuz like I said lots
of cool bands and people sending us
money in the mail we actually have a lot
of thank-yous because I had a couple
donations over PayPal and it was
actually like last week but we recorded
the show early because we were going
Tampa and I wanted to get it done out of
the way so you know I didn't have a
chance to thank him on the last episode
because I'd already recorded it so I
have to say thank you to Melanie who
sends his PayPal donations quite often
and they are always appreciated also you
get a new one from Lana so thank you
very much for that we also have a new
patron named Ilsa that's right so
welcome new $20 a week that's right yeah
and I would also like to thank major
consumer cos yeah for his contribution
which he sent through snail mail yeah
what you can do that to just read just
contacted me if you want the like
mailing address since your money order
huh
he did well it was like a cashier's
check I didn't like that but yeah that
was like super cool and like I said all
money sex it's all money is ready to
show money's money money's usually helps
like I said pay bills or like update
equipment which yeah we want to get a
new camera well I need to get a new
computer too not so much the laptop but
my desktop is anxious I don't even know
how old it is and actually he gave it to
us before he died yeah yeah and he had
it from back in then I mean you know
it's a PC and he he kept hot-rodding it
but you know I mean that's a dinosaur
now it is like I said I was surprised I
can still do if it's just a used one
that's in you know even one that was
five years old would be better than
would be better than that but yeah
that's got to be at least 50 probably
yeah I mean like I said it's been
updated oh it doesn't have Windows 10 on
it because I put Windows 10 on and it
[ __ ] everything else on it so I was
just using it for just kind of like
storing information for old shows and
stuff right no that's all going no I put
that all that on Dropbox on draw boxes
um mostly the only thing that I use that
PC for I mean I use it to write on
because I have like you know Microsoft
Word and [ __ ] on it and I also use it
for video editing or depending on what
if it's just like easy video editing
like the show like I usually use
wondershare filmora do and because
that's like an easy
yeah actually is if anybody's got a good
deal on a used one contact us yeah some
as long as like I said as long as it's
like not [ __ ]
ancient yeah like we're talking like
four or five years old yeah that would
be good it's yeah just kind of just I've
just been in the I don't know the money
of like right now but eventually I think
by the end of this month I'll think we
got it so much should we go take care of
I know I'm like you said we want to get
a new camera as well yeah um so yeah oh
also I've got already got like four or
five stories for the Halloween show you
probably have a couple more weeks to
send them before we start thinking about
recording it they're not real long are
they no okay um so if you would like to
send a story like I said a fictional one
or true story or whatever as long as
it's not super long you can send it to
my email um I'll put it in the
description but actually just send it to
grave cake at gmail.com don't be the
easiest thing to do tell me if you have
like a name that you want to go under or
whatever then let me know that as well
gotta have somebody over for Halloween
to do the show with us I know we really
should yeah we need to do like a fun
variety show yeah they will have little
folk come over no because then I'll just
be like sitting over here twiddling my
thumbs and you guys will just be talking
about like Rambo movie yes like for
three hours not very Halloweeny is it no
no I'm just saying I don't know we'll
think of something
we usually uh I usually try to like plan
it out ahead of time and that never
[ __ ] work though you know what I mean
so with it'll be like the week before
I'm just like oh [ __ ] it says we have to
do something and we have to figure it
out but yeah so I think that's pretty
much the only other shout outs like I
said face it's been three obviously if
you haven't read that yet or a few
Breton lives leave a review um
associated villainies like I said the
print in a book is up the audiobook is
taking a weirdly long time usually it
doesn't take this long I think I
uploaded it on September 18th or
something like that and usually it only
takes two weeks it may not be sold but
in I don't know you know um
but um you know it's been longer than
that and I'm not really sure why I'd hit
him up I mean they haven't sent me a
message saying there's a problem which
usually they would if there was because
a couple of times I had a couple of
files that were [ __ ] up and they let
now but I don't know maybe they're just
taking maybe they're just backed up
maybe they're backed up in that section
yeah that's what I'm thinking
and you know whatever we'll see how it
goes all right so as I said on this
episode we're gonna be covering some
creepy-ass
gross ass murders from the 19th century
like I said a lot of which kind of got
forgotten about because they happened
either in the same area at around the
same time period as the Jack the Ripper
murders which were kind of like the og
serial killer murders like everybody
just forgot about all the other [ __ ]
that happened that wasn't the only one
that was going on hell no right have you
guys ever seen the show it's a British
show called murder maps and I think like
the first season of it they did like a
whole bunch of other crimes that had
happened in England or actually maybe
just around London at around the same
time period as the Jack the Ripper thing
and it's like there was all kind of
crazy [ __ ] going on back then and it's
like that's all people think of when you
think of Victorian London like murders
it's Jack the Ripper murders but there
was so much other [ __ ] goin I think the
reason why that case really kind of
sticks out is because England had a very
developed media at that time a lot of
newspapers and photographs and [ __ ] of
the bodies you know I mean and it's and
it happened during a time when people
you know there was a lot of literature
going on so people wrote about I said I
think that I think it was the first one
to kind of become a media sensation yeah
I think it's the reason why I've even
remember it I guess though there was
because there was stuff going on in the
United States that that didn't stick
trail you know man like they knew it was
local there back in those days there
wasn't really a national media like you
have it today most these stores were
local stories well yeah because like I
said you know communication and travel
between cities was much harder obviously
England being a smaller place it's
easier for something to kind of go viral
and that's it you would that's true in
the United States just because of
geography it it might kind of go viral
in a city yeah like everybody in that
city yeah but outside outside as he
didn't know about it yeah because the
media wasn't the same there was no
internet there wasn't evening TV there
was evening radio yeah yeah no I don't
think you're really
dark Tosh [ __ ] times 2 I remember you
had to answer the phone find out who was
calling God did not suck yeah yeah
that's never put a stamp on a letter
wait for a reply yeah remember that I
see it yeah I used to be like a champion
lever letter writer man I store write to
people all its I used to write like
[ __ ] 20 page letters of people I
think things were easier to go viral in
the media of the Victorian era and
England yeah because it was a spending
was closer together yeah I gotcha that's
probably true
it could reach out and capture the
imagination of the entire population you
can do that United States yeah
maybe a New York area too far apart too
far apart everybody stay far apart right
now the first case I want to talk about
is the Thames torso murders and it's
weird to me that this does not get the
same amount of attention as the Jack the
Ripper was because it was just as
gruesome it actually started happening
earlier it started happening in 1873 and
actually went through Jack the Ripper's
entire thing and like went on till like
a year afterward and you know it was the
same type of thing there was like
mutilation dismemberment all this other
kind of [ __ ] they never caught the
person actually they're not entirely
sure it was the same person they're
pretty sure that you know all or most of
them were the same person that did it
but it just seems weird to me that Jack
the Ripper got super famous and the
Thames torso murderer whoever he or they
were is kind of forgotten about you know
what I mean because like I said I mean
according to your theory that would be
like media and they'd be like you'd
think that they'd be all over this [ __ ]
because like I said it's like [ __ ]
pieces of bodies turning up and [ __ ]
like that all the time - well me was
this after the Ripper it started before
started it started actually several
years before okay but carried on with
Daniel didn't carry on with it for a
while yeah maybe there's just something
that just didn't really capture the
imagination about the issue some of the
problem might have been that most of the
victims were not identify them it's a
big difference like one of the women
they found out who it was but the rest
of them they couldn't figure because
they were to cut up or they didn't
their heads or something like that right
so they couldn't put a face literally
they couldn't put a face to the victim
yeah and like no names or anything like
that couldn't make a compelling story
that's kind of what I'm leaning towards
so when you wrote it down the newspaper
it was just like yeah we found a torso
yeah we found like we don't know where
it came from and that's really all you
can say about that story you can't get
into victimology can't say oh this was
Mary a lot more material there to write
yet right you're in your tabloid yeah
that's that's probably why I do feel
like that is a factor of that right yes
so this person or persons like I said
very similar to a Jack the Ripper style
murder where they seemed to have
targeted some sex workers but some other
people as well
you know gruesome mutilations although I
feel like Jack the Ripper seemed a
little bit more I mean despite I think
in popular culture like a lot of people
think of him as like oh it's like
surgical precision and everything like
that but I think of him is like a rage
based killer because a lot of especially
his final victim if you've ever seen the
[ __ ] horrific crime scene photos of
that I mean he basically just tore her
apart it looked like a [ __ ] werewolf
had been in there come about the Ripper
yeah yeah whereas the tennis soccer
photos yeah that woman that woman laying
in bed just all you couldn't even tell
it was a person he was cutting on her
for a long time yeah taking pieces
pieces I know he was nan and eating on
him maybe from the photograph I saw it
looked kind of like he was eating some
of that yeah because in one of the
letters that he did send to the cops
he was cinema kidney huh never verified
as a human kidney I don't think it was
possible to do back in the matin oh they
didn't have DNA back then but anyway he
said he ate part that he ate half of it
yeah yeah if possible it's possible that
the Ripper was also kind of like water
to be a cannibal yeah like be about the
same personality type but you know the
person that did the Thames torso murders
though they did a similar kind of thing
but they seemed a lot more methodical
like a lot of the times the bodies that
were found
like very neatly cut up and packaged and
stuff it wasn't like there's like
[ __ ] guts everywhere and like [ __ ]
taken and why not yeah those Mexican
drug cartels do that all time that's
what I mean so it seemed much more like
that so I feel act achill reasons though
I feel like the yeah I feel like this
killer had like us maybe a slightly
different pathology than the Ripper he
wasn't working from the street yeah
doing that he's not working from the
street clearly he's got a plate he's got
a place
yeah house cuz I feel like Jack the
Ripper killed most of them in just in
the street where they miss plate or in a
room or in their aunt her room yeah but
no he took them someplace and killed
them and then did this and to cut him in
it like meat neatly neat pieces like
neat little four arms and four legs and
dies and taking the head off a lot of
times that that's not really part of the
crime that's all parsed postmortem and
it's a way to make them more portable
yeah so they can scatter the pieces
because for sure it's very also murders
yeah um they found the pieces like kind
of scattered around
well he's carrying him out of his house
there's a reitman little by little yeah
like I'm gonna take a couple these yeah
for armed I'm gonna take a leg you know
thigh today and I'm gonna go over here
I'm gonna drop it over there yeah and
I'll go back and I'll get the other
thigh so he's and he's got it in a small
package yeah like a small case so it
doesn't really attract any attention
he's probably doing it in his bathtub
yeah you know what I mean and a little
dismemberment yeah yeah so it's a place
to do it really it's a yeah it's a it's
just a clean way of getting the body out
of there without being noticed yeah cuz
you can't take him out once and hole you
know yeah yeah is it okay so as I said
now the tennis torso murders since they
were the person was never identified
they don't know if it was actually one
or more person and it was doing this
most people think that maybe it was six
victims for our canonical they're like
the official Tim story murders but there
are two more that they
think we're probably the same person of
the same killer same MO [ __ ] like that
this guy also did a little bit of the
taunting the cops type of thing but not
quite in the same way that Jack the
Ripper did it like where he was sending
the letters and whatnot but I'll get
into that in a little bit so the first
body that's found or at least piece of a
body this is pretty gross you guys
September 5th
1873 this was near the Battersea Pier in
the southwest part of London they the
police found part of a woman's torso
I've lose the left side in the mud on
the banks of the Thames River now as the
day went on various other people cops
you know they've kind of expanded the
search and everything and there were
other workers in the area as well
they also found more parts of what they
presumed was the same body including the
right side of the torso torso they found
some of the lungs the following day they
found a woman's face and a scalp which
had been detached from the head okay
these were found floating in the water
in Limehouse which I guess I'm not
really sure where that is then either
that same day or the next day then they
found a thigh and they found a right
shoulder okay cuz he if he's taken the
face off of the skulls huh this isn't
just merely a thing of convenience yeah
this is a fetishist yeah he's having fun
with him mm-hmm
you know he may have done that while
they were alive yeah all right
back then I mean there was no way of
knowing they I don't even think they
identified any causes of death on any of
these there's uh if you go on you know
if you go on like DuckDuckGo that search
engine and just put Mexican cartel
victims and just go to photographs and
videos a photograph that'll lead you to
some wild [ __ ] yeah there's a very
famous video where they knock some dude
out and they cut his face off and peel
it off and cut both hands off and when
he comes to he's trying to figure out
why his face is wet and sees what's
happened his face is laying in front of
this [ __ ] [ __ ] horrible yeah why yeah
like how would you even [ __ ] think of
that I mean yeah I mean you know it's
like tribal warfare
these cartels fight me I thought I would
think of it because I'm a [ __ ]
tying dudes up to like a bed frame and
hanging him over a fire with 50 gallon
oil drums in four corners of it you know
I'm watching him cook yeah it's so you
know there's some bad [ __ ] that happens
in his world
well yeah just look just look for it
you'll you'll see it well this dude may
have cut that woman's face off peel off
she was alive it's possible like I said
this was 1873 they would have been able
to determine that back then I don't know
they didn't have DNA they didn't have I
don't even think they had blood typing
in 1873 and I'm pretty sure that they
would didn't use fingerprinting at least
not widely because I think
fingerprinting only kind of started to
come into play like right around the
Jack the Ripper murders and that was
like several years after this if he had
a place to do all this and not be caught
there's a chance I'd probably give it a
25% chance that he skinned that her face
off her skull while she was alive yeah
but 75% chance it was done postmortem
work and be quiet you know the man they
didn't find her head ever they just
found out her face is gone and the scalp
yeah so there is some sadistic [ __ ]
going on in there
maybe post-mortem mostly it's mostly
sports but post-mortem if you just look
at the damn yeah if you look at the
statistics you know they played with
these dead bodies cuz they have sex with
him they're necrophiles yeah now they
found that torso in the mud which tells
me he dropped it off at night yeah two
halves of the torch yeah he tried to
throw it he couldn't see where the banks
were he threw it think thinking's going
into water was yeah [ __ ] it too late now
I'm not going down there go get it yeah
because that'll look up even more so
yeah so here's like a [ __ ] up don't
think I've been handling dead bodies not
a humans but a deer and [ __ ] you know I
mean I know what it out of its it but
you could just put yourself in that
position
murder not murder you just you just put
yourself in that position you're trying
to get rid of this thing and throw it
into the water and you hear it go boy
yeah it's just ten stories just as the
reason what happened
know what I mean right so the [ __ ] up
thing about this is that they find this
[ __ ] poor woman's body in [ __ ]
puzzle pieces essentially so they have
the police surgeon whose name is dr.
Kempster and him and his little officers
well maybe they were big officers I
don't know um but they tried to
reassemble the body on a kind of a frame
that they had I guess it was like some
kind of mechanical who is that that was
the my computer popped on because I
guess I knew the cat hey stop attacking
that everybody's making noise she wants
out so she's trying to know okay um the
most fucked-up thing about this to me
and actually last podcast on the left
talked about this a little bit too and
it's like I was listening to it earlier
they're like way bigger [ __ ] than
where like making jokes about this
horrible [ __ ] and everything like that
but it was still like pretty [ __ ]
funny but so they were talking about
they they took the woman's face which
had been peeled off and they like
stretched it over a butcher's block like
I guess to make it look more like a
human head no trying to yeah and then
they were trying to identify her so they
had it like on display so people who had
like loved ones that were missing yes
they come in and look at this but you
know obviously a face like on a head
like where it's supposed to be and a
peeled off face on a butcher's block
kind of hard to tell how old was a
victim um they thought that she was
maybe around 40 um she had like short
dark hair that was kind of thinning they
said really there she didn't have a lot
of identifying marks they did find like
kind of a burn scar like on her left
breast like on one side it said they
thought that you know hopefully that
someone would recognize that scar I
would recognize her face so but no one
did like a whole bunch of people trooped
through to see this [ __ ] horrible
like sad face like [ __ ] on the
cheapest from far away block maybe I'm
not really sure
I mean her family was old maybe no they
didn't hear about it yeah I mean they
took a bunch of photos of it and stuff
like that and they kind of like passed
him around like the Battersea area to
see if anyone recognized her but
apparently no one
did so her remains were buried at the
cemetery there in Battersea now the next
year there was another victim found this
was also a woman her she was missing her
head both her hands and her feet she was
also never able to be identified so he
didn't Diskin he didn't disconnect the
arms and legs sometimes he did and
sometimes he did it that's odd yeah he
had a way of getting her out of wherever
it was he was working with maybe he had
a carriage yeah you'd have to be able to
carry her yeah so he might have had his
own carriage that's all I could think of
yeah or a wagon yeah so maybe he was
like a little bit more wealthy might
have been a wagon yeah a horse and a
wagon might have been part of his job I
just feel like they were just probably
card it around all kind of horrible [ __ ]
back then so it's like I don't think
like like you said it was like so much
easier to get away with stuff back then
it is you know what I mean like like
though everywhere was filthy everyone
was like he could have had a cart a push
cart yeah like some vendors would use
back in those days and I mean you put
two big wheels on it you pick it up push
it she probably weighed that much yeah
he something work-related yeah possibly
yeah but now while they weren't able to
they did get a cause of death on the
first victim whose face was stretched
over the butcher block they determined
that she had probably been killed by
blunt force trauma to the head I guess
they could see that because like of some
kind of wound that they could see on the
scalp however the victim that they found
the following year whose head hands and
feet were missing they never could
determine the cause of death she had
just been killed somehow and then cut up
and they never found her feet or her
hands or her head probably same thing
blunt force trauma the head probably the
other one had a head smashed in in the
back or something yeah probably so he
probably did the same there so then
comes May of 1887 now this victim is
actually for whatever reason this is
considered the first official Tim story
so murder even though there were two
before this that were let's face it
probably the same person in a way you
kind of hoped it would the same bar
things you don't want two of these
[ __ ] lunatics running around yeah so
this victim was found in the Thames
wrapped up like in a bundle now they
found it's there were different body
parts washing up like over the ensuing
few weeks and 1887 so they pretty much
over the weeks they pulled they kept
pulling all these body parts out of the
river the only thing they never found
was the head in the neck but everything
else washed up at some point and they
kind of like puzzled puzzled the victim
together now the victim had been in the
water for so long and was so decomposed
and stuff like that they couldn't really
tell anything about her like cause of
death like nothing like that they said
that we we know it's a woman and that's
about it you know and I thought this was
funny in like last Pat last podcast on
the Left mentioned this as well but they
said the only description that was put
like on the record the death certificate
or whatever was found dead I'm like yeah
no [ __ ] she was like all [ __ ] cut up
did they ever find any heads aside from
that I believe they did not I don't
think they found I think he's keeping
that he's keeping the heads yeah you
know why cuz he had small enough to go
in an ice box that's exactly what I was
thinking I said he's probably got a
whole freezer full of heads if they
didn't have a freezers but they did have
like yeah he could keep it fresh heard
he was doing to those heads with
what's-his-name was doing yeah [ __ ]
Bundy Bundy yeah those heads yeah that's
the first thing I thought of to you
because it's like interesting how the
heads the only thing not found yeah
creepy you could keep that fresh longer
weird dudes man well yeah that we are
doing way of putting it yeah and he
didn't keep the first head or he didn't
keep the first face was he having sex
with the head that didn't have a face on
it yeah maybe he was trying it both ways
that's some weird like to see what would
he like to call dead he's going bareback
on it Oh
Oh Dennis even did it while warden
Arthur even Dennis terrible time he's a
serial killer
Dennis Rader didn't approve this that
was even too much yeah it was all my
cameras down boy it was still funny that
I don't know why you would come up with
someone and just talk about that in
public it was so funny but that's not
like putting on woman's panties or
anything good night grave and take a
picture yourself I mean you know that's
totally cool yes that's our yeah all
right so now the next victim happened on
was found on September 11th 1888 now
this here I think this was I believe
this was like two murders that happened
like in very close proximity to one
another and this became known in the
press as the Whitehall mystery now what
they ended up finding first was they
found a right arm and shoulder on an
embankment near Pimlico now at first
because apparently this was a thing at
first when they just found the arm and
[ __ ] they thought oh well it's medical
students playing a prank because
apparently that was something that
medical students would do was that they
would take you know cadavers that they
were working on or take them from the
morgue or whatever and would leave
pieces of them around town just for
shits and giggles seemed plausible I
knew there was a lot of grave robbery
and medical students live like that and
they were they probably were kind of
sheltered that he didn't believe there
was such thing for you just you know
serial killers although the dumb thing
about this is that when they found this
arm it should be noted if you know
anything about Jack the Ripper this was
September 1888 Jack the Ripper had
already killed two women at this point
Polly Nichols in any Chapman he had
already killed them it was a different
time I guess just like what is it's you
know they just find like [ __ ] horses
and arms and [ __ ] they're like no big
[ __ ] you know yeah those medical
students yeah they're so they're so
crazy
their shenanigans yeah so yeah that's
the thing so Jack Tripper had killed two
victims at this point although it should
be noted that the dear boss letter had
not arrived at the Central News Agency
yet so I guess it was kind of that
letter that more launched him into like
media infamy more than the murders did I
guess so because it was kind of this
Twilight period in between like a couple
of murders and before the media like
getting all [ __ ] outrageous about it
said no one really cared I guess or
didn't work all that concerned so
September 28th which was the day after
the dear boss letter from Jack the
Ripper came to the media they found
another arm just lying by the side of
the road then October 2nd 1888
there was another woman's torso found
kind of wrapped up and it was found by a
construction worker in an unfinished
vault near Whitehall in Westminster now
interestingly enough and this is why
they think that maybe this murderer was
kind of taunting the police a little bit
was that this unfinished place where
they were constructing it was gonna be
the new Metropolitan Police Headquarters
and this ballsy [ __ ] dumped a
woman's torso right in the middle of it
yeah almost like like he knew like yeah
well taunting them catch me well you
know back in those back in that era
police were not in a modern force it may
have been kind of considered a modern
force in England but not really not in
the United States but they were more
like rent-a-cops
yeah another man yeah I mean they
weren't even they weren't even really
modern cops until even in the 20s that's
why you know Bonnie and Clyde cut a
swath room so you know so yeah so
cleanly you know be like kind of like
attacking ball cops and depending on
mall cops back in those days they do
forensics and no training or anything
enough so you could get away with [ __ ]
like this yeah there wasn't much to him
well yeah it's like what the [ __ ] could
they do like I said if when you think
about all the tech
logical advances that have been made in
the last you know 20 50 years prior to
that I'm honestly amazed they ever
caught anyone yeah and I think most of
the ones that they caught were just
because somebody came forward said yeah
I did that [ __ ] well modern people take
police for granted yeah
you know what I mean there's police now
so they they're just like yeah that
they're the police they're the ones that
keep the peace and catch all the
criminals they also believe you know
we're kind of raised to believe that not
only were they always hears that you
absolutely need them you don't you don't
you know you know you know the most
civilizations throughout history didn't
have them you know ancient Rome didn't
have police yeah it had soldiers but
they didn't have police a civilization
can get by without them as will there be
crime hell yeah yeah and you'll have
serial killers that will never be caught
yeah you know yeah there's a lot of
serial killers that were never caught
never caught even with the cops the
effectiveness of the cosmoses deterrence
yeah and you know if you actually kind
of look at what cops are doing in any
kind of given area that they work in the
average do you know what they're doing
on average is writing tickets because
that's where the that's where the
revenue comes from you know they keep
the to keep the police station going and
paying the bills they're mostly not
catching murderers yeah you know
organized crime organized criminals and
serial killers a lot of that ends up
being FBI you know it's expecially units
it's just it's just kind of weird you
know when you think about it you can't
take the police for granted but most
most civilizations up until recently
didn't really have them yeah yeah and
then there were Wesley just had
sheriff's which was just he might have a
couple deputies they were like they were
basically the bar bouncers for the town
yeah and when they needed anything done
they just gather up a posse or a militia
to go out and hunt somebody down you
know but could those Old West sheriff's
deal with a serial killer
[ __ ] no no no not somebody of this
magnitude
because like I said you know yeah there
are a lot of serial killers and I'm
finding about out you know about new
ones like all the time which is very
upsetting but also you have to consider
how many billions of people there are in
the world and this is still very rare
yeah so I do feel and I do feel like
particularly back in the old days like
where people didn't really have any
concept of like a sexual sadist
yeah who would just kill people for the
[ __ ] of it yeah you know what I mean
they didn't really most of the regular
people didn't have yeah intercept of
that exactly in the early system did not
have an answer to that didn't even
really think that that was a problem
yeah you know they knew that it appeared
every now and then but they they just
thought I mean it's very rare there's
that Amelie yeah I think going back in
my in my memory as far as all these
cases goes that we've discussed in the
United States the first real serial
killer that they identified and hunted
down and got would have been HH Holmes
yeah and that [ __ ] was like
something out of the damn [ __ ] Phantom
of the Opera basically he was like
something out of Phantom of the Opera he
had his own [ __ ] tortured castle he
had some showmanship going hell yeah and
that you know and that's actually that
book Gaston Leroux from the 1800s when
you [ __ ] read that book man it sounds
like it sounds like a mommy that's
already got the idea yeah I think they I
mean maybe that's where HH Holmes got
the idea maybe but yeah you know I mean
uh how did they catch HH Holmes that was
it wasn't a Secret Service was it there
was no FBI then no it was lawyers wasn't
it that kind of thing I can't really
remember trying to put it together cuz
he kept he kept making all those damn
insurance claims and I think that's what
local and long is it the insurance
people yeah it wasn't at the Pinkertons
Pinkerton Thea wasn't it the Pinkertons
the gab which I was a private security
company yeah they're private detectives
you're right and that was the closest
thing to and they were the Secret
Service for a while yeah you know so
that was the only thing I could deal
with serial killer yeah cops couldn't
deal with that [ __ ] it wasn't their job
nothing not back in those I'm like I
said you
well you know most cops back then
wouldn't have encountered it and their
entire nose it would you be aware of it
is unusual
they wouldn't you may worry they would
know what a rapist was yeah you know but
a serial killer they that's a whole
other out of their depth yeah so now it
turned out that the you know old-timey
equivalent of a coroner that they had
back then medical examiner they they
noticed that this arm that they had
found on September 28th had actually had
a tourniquet on it before it had been
cut off damn so she alive so she might
have been alive when she was being cut
apart which is [ __ ] up told you he was
probably doing some of that stuff while
she was well yeah yeah so so at this
point they're saying okay well obviously
this is somebody with some knowledge of
anatomy perhaps they are you know
medical student perhaps they're a
butcher
perhaps they are what they used to call
a [ __ ] which was somebody that dealt
with um you know carcasses of animals
you know he would go and collect them
and then break them down for processing
like for turning a noise or whatever
it's an old law enforcement guys back in
that area to always jump to these
conclusion well he must have some kind
of knowledge some kind of training yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] medical knowledge and
scientific training of that era you
could condense it down into prior 50
page book yeah I mean um how to cut a
body apart I mean that was not too far
from the era where the company barber
did all the amputations in the [ __ ]
army unit during college and pulled
others and pulled all the teeth it
doesn't take a whole lot of [ __ ]
knowledge to take up it to take an arm
off I mean the dudes that we're doing
this we're not geniuses well I figure
even if like back then if you knew how
to like cut up a chicken yeah and
everybody could probably figure it out
everybody did people [ __ ] butch it
their own food but can kill black
chicken do these and in America they'd
kill a damn chicken you know take it out
of the coop and [ __ ] pull all the
feathers off of it and there you go you
know how to clean a fish yeah yeah it's
like it's just
yeah it's just it's not it's just
somebody with the guts to do it that's
that's all it is yeah I'm not sure I'd
use that word but yeah or the set or
just a psychopathy to do it the body
he's affecting fantasizing about how to
[ __ ] cut somebody apart alive mm-hmm
all he does is go down and go get the
books on how to do that that's all the
doctors did back then yeah read about it
in a book yeah tried it a couple times
there you go yep yeah that's all it is
yeah so this these body parts that they
found they actually determined that the
victim was 24 years old of quote large
stature and well nourished but that is
big effect but that was about all they
could determine about her again she was
obviously never identified now the
morning of a June 4th 1889 there were
some boys playing in the Thames near
Battersea Park under the Albert Bridge
and saw an object lapping against the
embankment whenever there to check out
what it was and again it was a human arm
now these boys are core they wrapped up
the arm and they brought it to Scotland
Yard I guess yeah although kids nowadays
my teeth defendant wishes to spend it on
the kid oh yeah they probably sent that
[ __ ] all the time yeah so he brings it
to Doug they bring it to dr. Kempster um
he figured it wasn't like all that you
know gross or bloated or rotten or
anything like that so he said so it
couldn't have been in the water you know
more than 24 hours or you know probably
less than 24 hours it was actually
wrapped up in like a piece it had been
wrapped in like a piece of like a coat
or a shirt or something like that that
had the name Ellie Fisher on it now over
the next few days they found a bunch
more body parts from the same victim and
again this looked like it had been cut
up like a butcher would cut up like a
carcass so they're thinking maybe it's a
butcher or an actor like I said now this
victim because the garment that was
wrapped around one of the body parts
they found a scar on the wrist and also
the victim was eight months
pregnant they were actually able to
identify this woman her name was
Elizabeth Jackson she was pregnant she
was eight months pregnant yeah well yeah
that's almost ready to pop like a Jiffy
Pop uh she was originally from County
Cork Ireland but had fallen on hard
times
was had been homeless and was living in
London and was working as a prostitute
in Soho Square she was 24 years old so
now when she got killed the newspapers
started to try to link her in with the
Ripper crime but even police back then I
mean yeah they didn't have like all the
[ __ ] modern [ __ ] we have now but they
weren't that dumb they did determine
that it's like the modus operandi of the
Ripper murders and the Thames torso
murders were different enough that you
could tell that it wasn't probably
wasn't the same person so even though
there was some speculation in the media
that Elizabeth Jackson had been a victim
of the Ripper most police thought that
was very unlikely now another thing that
and like I said this killer also taunted
the police and the media and kind of
like had a little bit of a showmanship
thing going on another thing that he did
was he took Elizabeth Jackson's right
thigh and he threw it over the wall of
the home of Percy and Mary Shelley Mary
Shelley who wrote Frankenstein about a
body that was she knew about them yeah
well that was like a hugely popular book
at the time like everybody read it so um
so yeah so that's kind of funny giving
them something to write about I guess oh
it's like that's like it's kind of it's
horrible but it's also kind of like Oh
Fair Play
all right well tell you what he's got a
job he's got a place to do this and he's
got some kind of a cart some kind of a
wagon to get those bodies out of there
yeah if you're saying you know I mean
yeah so the last victim are the last
canonical victim of the
torsade murders is actually the one
that's most usually like tied in with
the Ripper murders just because the body
was found in Whitechapel this happened
on September 10th 1889 which was you
know about a year after the Jack the
Ripper murders had stopped a woman's
torso was found under the railway arch
on Pynchon Street in Whitechapel there
were no legs and no head but the arms
were still attached to the torso which
was unusual because usually he'd cut the
arms off they never did find the legs
they never did find the head like I said
I don't think they found any of the
heads just a face now they were also
able to determine that the woman had not
been killed there and that the killer
had possibly killed the woman elsewhere
and then dumped her in Whitechapel to
make it look like the Ripper had done it
but like you said the Ripper usually
would kill the women in situ you know
what where he found them he would kill
them in an alley or something then just
leave them there
this woman was clearly not killed where
she was found you know what I mean and
she was like so cut up and like they
didn't find like body parts and [ __ ]
like that so I feel like he did it in
his house probably and then dumped it in
Whitechapel to be either either because
he was making a joke about the Ripper he
was trying to pin it on the Ripper I'm
not really sure you get the rippers
attention or get the rippers attention
like hey brah
yeah we're both serial killers high-five
but yes so he's on your territory bro
maybe that's it it was maybe he was like
[ __ ] talking yeah like where you at like
serial killers [ __ ] talk yeah yeah where
you at yeah oh man yeah it was like a
dis yeah now actually I kind of hope
that's true
well like I know that's a terrible thing
to say it was more like a communication
I'm doing my thing you're doing your
thing let's go yeah yeah yeah so this
woman again Elizabeth Jackson who was
killed previously was the only one that
was identified this woman was also never
identified and buried in East London so
so these people these girls that are
disappearing probably prostitutes when
they go disappear in or when it went
when they go missing no one reports them
no um and like I said the only one that
was identified Elizabeth Jackson was
from Ireland
which kind of makes me feel like maybe a
lot of the other women were not from
London I was thinking so their families
were not there he knows them yeah I was
there their backgrounds yeah
which leads me to think that he's a
regular job they trust yeah they'll go
with him so he goes to a local little
scene where all these hookers are
hanging out I do feel that he just dates
if that's he want to call yeah he gets
to know him and then the ones that he
gets to know the ones that he finds out
don't have any connections or either
from somewhere else they're somewhere
else he takes those maybe that's what it
is he's that way was establishing I feel
like a lot of serial killers probably do
that that way when they vanish no one
notices yeah until they find the body
and they can't figure out who that is
cuz he's got the head yeah so that's how
he's covering his tracks
yeah but he's a regular customer to a
bunch of other ones I wonder if the
Ripper was as well I don't know I don't
know maybe yeah I don't probably less
likely because they weren't really going
anywhere with him
trail they knew this dude you know yeah
and maybe he didn't even suspect
anything suspect him they knew him they
knew him they thought he was a good dude
yeah
and he's going to he might have three or
four little cuts where he hangs out look
cut his place where you know where all
the hookers are yeah just got three or
four little cuts that he goes to he's
got a good reputation you know the lingo
you know he goes to there and he's got a
good reputation in there he's spent a
lot of money the you know I mean it's
regular is a regular customer he sees a
new girl show up he finds out she's not
from that area he kills that one yeah
all right the other girls don't even
notice that she's gone they just sir
like way cuz she's new and she's new she
went somewhere else yeah she must have
just taken off right I mean obviously he
did a really good job yeah in a [ __ ]
up way be
not only was he never caught but all but
one of his victims were not identified
were never identified still not I must
say he's popular yeah among those girls
he's popular yeah maybe they know like
super nice and like I said they didn't
have any reason to suspect no reason to
suspect him within more creepy and the
ones that will dress anybody and the
ones that were local and well-known he
didn't kill those he killed the new ones
that we're showing up from out of town
yeah
and we're taking them out before they
got established yeah you know what I
mean
so they didn't have any ties to any ties
to the area and the reason why the new
girls trusted him is because he had a
good reputation with this with the other
ones right but he hadn't killed right
well he was what the call he's what you
would probably call like a high-value
John yeah okay so the new girls were
like oh that one yeah yeah I'm good yeah
they're all doing business with him yeah
and what's not killing them and it's
like maybe he's nice to them like I said
and maybe he spends like [ __ ] tons of
money yes every now and then right now
you know this is over a hard years ago
yeah but I'm just trying to put myself
back in that time and in that situation
and that's probably what he's doing that
would make the most sense to me he ain't
on a monster and like I said visually
not yet like only just no way deep down
and he's probably you know 40s yeah he's
a guy in his forties who's an
established merchant of some sort yeah
because he seems like I mean the Jack
the Ripper murders that was five very
gruesome murders that happened in a
pretty short period time it was only
like over a couple months it was almost
it was almost like a spree yeah whereas
this guy I mean 1873 was the first one
they think 1889 was the last one so he
was like they were going a year like in
between so he was somebody that seems
like they could just like bide their
time he's like Dennis or or like
Ridgeway the he's like Mary save up for
the [ __ ] they're married yeah they got
why I ain't got fam
[ __ ] this is it there's special projects
that's way that that's probably exactly
the type of dude this was because like I
said the fact that they were so far
apart and that and that when he got one
he would make this big production like
cutting it up and like leaving him and
please yeah it was like maybe once every
six months or something yeah I weren't
ever found that type of deal yeah maybe
he killed more than that and they just
nailed them so i'ma probably just more
family cuz seriously the biggie back
then it was like [ __ ] disgusting in
dirt I doing this a couple times a year
yeah yeah possibly cuz like I said the
first couple were a year apart I believe
yeah yeah I bet she's twice that
probably what he's actually doing yeah
yeah there's not finding the parts man
can you imagine like I always wonder if
like somebody like like you said he
can't kept all the heads like somewhere
like an icebox or whatever and then like
and then like he died and then like the
next person that moved in what's the
[ __ ] heads in there I think what
you're dealing with is just dealing with
a tradesman okay he might be a food
vendor or somebody he's got a cart and
he goes to the local market and he's
selling stuff he might have in the back
there inside the wood that where the
lamb is and all the [ __ ] pork he
might have a wrapped up ahead you might
have two or three I met there yeah
okay and no one would know that no one
would notice it's up there with all the
rest of the meat to the meat and he's
working by himself so he's a small
business owner yeah you know probably
like I said married with kids
yeah and got a cart that he pushes
things to the market with and that's
where how he's getting rid of them
[ __ ] body creepy like I said can't
trust anybody but they did say maybe he
was a butcher so yeah yeah maybe they
thought butcher or like I said a [ __ ]
yeah so they're in the right track yeah
i price a butcher yeah because they
thought that the way the bodies were cut
up they're like it's not like a surgeon
at the time would do it was more like a
butcher would do like on a pig kiss or
something yeah although you might he
might even just be a grocer though he
might be doing with fruit yeah he might
be doing with you know I mean it's a
very similar true
but they're thinking along the same
lines I'm thinking yeah to get get rid
of those bodies he's gotta had a cart or
a wagon yeah and he's got it either
yeah and he can push that thing around
and not be noticed yeah that was the
eighteen hundred's version to having a
damn white van yeah the white molester
right no way
everybody's got a white van this is
freakin Indians yeah yeah so yeah this
is like the 19th century equivalent of
[ __ ] Dennis right yeah what's guy
like Dennis yeah yeah you think so it
does well of course you know he knows
what he's doing
yeah well you know he's we hang out the
cut you meet certain kind of women and
you know I was always like good girls
but you know each each man was on yeah
he was never caught at sea he knew what
he was doing
thank you very much for that there are
some there are some subscribers that
want me to do the entire show as Dennis
yes I can't do a whole [ __ ] show is
dead I think you won't be able to keep a
straight face
yeah well like I said we should do an
offshoot series where he gives like
advice on sexual you have to be slightly
you have to be slightly pissed off its
like the indignant and then you have to
be like real arrogant to be Dennis yeah
yeah I know you guys think that you
caught me but you really didn't catch me
you only apprehended me after I did my
thing say so that's not the same as
catching me and I'm alright I knew I
wanted this is my retirement plan you're
all we're all just doing what I wanted
it's time for me to cash in my credits
you know our man is old don't worry
everybody would know that arm the BTK
yeah how everyone take care of you all
the taxpayers take care of you in your
twilight years yeah yeah see he's just
like hang out and watch TV I would like
to sit around on your ass I would like
to go to his prison and I can go meet
Dennis
do an interview with Danis you have fun
with that we're gonna be with Dennis and
then you write a book about it yeah yeah
what are you gonna talk to him about
talk about sexual prowess we already
know all about Dennis and sexual ones
I'll shake you tell our staff though
probably you probably tell celesta how
much of it could you actually believe it
doesn't matter you just write a book
about what he said yeah that's you know
I mean let other people pick through it
BTK speaks yeah BTK speaks well if he'll
talk to you then yeah Brian doctor
probably Rico you'd probably talk to you
you think probably would oh yeah oh yeah
I'd love to have you all of it bought my
visitors list Jenny come visiting time
your water yeah well answer all your
questions if I tell you everything
[Laughter]
hit the floor would have no Edie saying
you love letters and [ __ ] ah see I know
your song for your birthday
oh you remind me of my wife I swear to
god people I'll be back here one time
I'd be riding on the back of the hit
here from the back oh hey Jenny yeah and
I'll be like hang on start proper we're
laughing now but I'm not sure I'm gonna
feel about promising Jenny will not do
Raiders voice [ __ ] we're throwing
down [ __ ] Dennis trying to be cool
[ __ ] rapping and [ __ ] oh my god you
should do a rap album yeah Dennis good
dance rap
Oh MCB have no rhythm yeah I have no
rhythm at all come on that would be
awesome yeah I'm thinking about it that
would be awesome
at least do a song and you could call it
sexual problem cause sexual problems I
got 99 problems and I throw I had to
hire somebody we assuming we know from
where these bands to flicker right yeah
you could do like bad hip hop real bad
like it was the backings fact that's how
we'll wrap everything I need the lyrics
[ __ ] all right so uh we yeah we're done
talking about the Thames tour summer
that's it yeah so next we're gonna talk
about the servant girl Annihilator you
gonna take a break though right yeah in
in just a moment all right yeah I'm
Tanya this dude was kind of dude like
Rader he was a guy like Dennis Rader
yeah probably
except like an old-time Avis ryan
version yeah
all right we're back I just we just came
back from a break and I walked into our
room in there I leave new retro wave
play it and Cora was on there that song
that song I just told you heaven
Thurmond heaven sermon load some of that
[ __ ] in there real quick Jenny that's
just so [ __ ] awesome okay I got to
turn people on to this band that [ __ ]
and live they were [ __ ] great in
every song they [ __ ] have is awesome
oh yeah oh yeah
[Music]
all right we're back all right so the
next case we're gonna talk about another
kind of famous case from the 19th
century which actually occurred a few
years before the jakab Reverend writers
happened right here in the US of A
specifically in Austin Texas this is the
case of the servant girl Annihilator yet
another [ __ ] who was never
caught
yet another [ __ ] yet another
[ __ ] yeah that ought to be a
name of something a name of something
this I'm gonna start a band called know
whatever forget it what up yeah so yeah
again so this killer is thought to have
been responsible for the murder of eight
people it reminds me a lot of the Axman
of New Orleans case which happened you
know a couple decades after this but in
this sense that this a lot of these were
acts murders and all so this person
would come in to people's houses and
either kill them in their beds or drag
them out into their yards and kill them
and also did like really extensive
mutilations as I said again never caught
now the interesting thing I was watching
um like a lecture that'll you know a
library in Texas somewhere by a a guy
named skip Hollandsworth and he wrote a
book about this case called the midnight
assassin because I guess the servant
girl Annihilator is considered because
we were just talking about HH Holmes but
I guess this Irma girl Annihilator is
considered the first American serial
killer you know what I mean because this
happened in 1884 like they started in
late 1884 as I said a few years before
the Jack the Ripper murders yeah now
that's the first American serial killer
that they caught I'm sure they're well
no they didn't catch them or if they did
until my HH Holmes yeah I'm sure that
that's the first one they identified God
I'm sure there were other ones yeah I
don't think they even knew what a serial
killer was until HH arms appeared yeah
it stands to reason that I'm like I said
they didn't have a term for it until the
39th
yeah I think the whole concept of a dude
who's a sexual sadist
he's basically a serial rapist who's
killing people in these weird ways that
had to have been around before but they
couldn't have imagined that I don't
think yeah and I'm sure they got away
with it
yeah I'm sure a lot of probably did yeah
because they know they were killing
people that were like some people were
killing people that were travelers yeah
or like or otherwise transient so it's
right it's right you know if you're
riding the rails all over the country
and like killing people in a town then
the train to go to the next thing they'd
never [ __ ] care there have been
instances of them [ __ ] demolishing
old American houses and buildings that
were well over a hundred and something
years old this is just off the top of my
head I can't name anything just remember
reading it some of these things were
like 150 years old houses had been
abandoned for 6070 years and underneath
that house they'd five [ __ ] like 8080
damn graves yeah you know so something
was going on I might have been like
bed-and-breakfast type deals you know I
mean they were long going on like some
of those ladies we talked about on the
last [ __ ] show that were just
poisonous yeah so there were serial
killers it's just that they didn't know
about him until HH Holmes yeah well look
at the case of like the bloody benders
that has yeah yeah in Kansas or wherever
that was
right which is cross between like a
serial killer a [ __ ] pirate and some
kind of weird-ass some patchy yeah cuz
like boy just hey stop it our little in
yeah yeah oh and on the blade there's
some time with you who was the other guy
the guy that was they were the wat the
two brothers that were from Ireland or
some wild men that were in slave and
women and [ __ ] we talked about them
before uh the heart heart brother the
heart brother says go back that was like
almost a 1600 or 1700 I don't remember
how I don't remember there was some wild
[ __ ] going on going on going way back
yeah some bone tomahawk [ __ ] hmm
yeah well yeah that's why that movie
works right so these took place in the
city of Austin Texas now interestingly
about the end of the Civil War 1865 the
City of Austin only had a population of
about 5,000 people but by the time the
murders started in 1885 the population
had
voted to 14,500 people they were in the
middle of constructing a humongous new
Capitol building there were all kind of
fancy hotels fancy restaurant stuff like
that so it was really becoming like kind
of a boomtown it happened like in a very
short amount of time like only about 20
years so as I said the first victim of
the sort of who would never be called
the servant girl Annihilator this
happened in December December 30th 1884
the first victim was Molly Smith she was
a young black woman she was a cook and
she was actually found lying in the snow
near her employer's home with a big huge
axe wound in the middle of her head she
had also been stabbed in the abdomen in
the chest in the legs and in the arms
and she was lying in a pool of blood so
large that one sight I said said that
she appeared to be floating in it now
the axe wound was one that killed her
I'm guessing yes ran her down was
stabbing on her and she hit the ground
begging for mercy he had that accent ha
yeah cut her head open like I said this
is what this kind of reminded reminds me
of the later you know yeah
ax man of New Orleans murder the next
victim was another young black woman he
was also a cook her name was Eliza
Shelley her body was found on May 7th
1885 her head was almost split in half
with an axe the third victim was
attacked on May 23rd she was also a
black woman she was a servant her name
was Irene cross she was stabbed multiple
times with a knife and also scalped so
that's nice yeah now as I said and I
think I mentioned this in the
introduction the killer got the name the
servant girl Annihilator because if the
very famous short story writer oh Henry
he was writing a letter to his friend in
which he was talking about Austin and he
said quote town is fearfully dull except
for the frequent raids of the servant
girl Annihilator x' who make things
lively during the dead
hours of the night yeah now it should be
noted that I don't believe anyone
referred to the killers the servant girl
Annihilator at the time it was just like
after that letter kind of become became
better known like you know they started
referring good because that's a pretty
bitchin name I mean at the time I
believe it you know if the guy that
wrote the book about it like I said I
was watching a talk with him earlier but
he was saying that the media at the time
called the killer the intangible Menace
yeah or the intangible nemesis I'm like
wow it sounds like a [ __ ]
supervillain to me he almost sounds kind
of like the Atlanta Ripper that's right
yeah it's very similar kind of thing to
that too and like I said x-men of New
Orleans it just seems like a very
similar type of type of yeah if you guys
don't know who the Atlanta Ripper is we
did all show on it I think wasn't it a
whole show yeah you guys can watch that
show yeah that was the black Jack the
Ripper yeah that'd make an awesome movie
that would have made a really awesome
it's really weird to me that that case
is not better around right same with the
same with this one I feel like more
people know the servant girl Annihilator
than they do and let her rip Raven yeah
Lanta Ripper was a guy who wore a big
overcoat big brimmed hat was young black
guy said he could jump over damn walls
and fences like a cat and we just run up
behind young black girls and [ __ ]
stab them yeah let's street snowy say
[ __ ] to him yes one of them even took
her heart out yeah and like left it next
error in his 20s I think that was his
last pitch it's just an acrobatic kind
of like the shadow yeah you know crazy
dude kind of did you know well he was in
where he was the Ripper who's the
Atlanta Ripper
yeah now it should be noted that as rad
as the name servant girl Annihilator is
really only the first few victims were
servants or cooks or whatever the rest
of them were just other different types
of people and in fact the fourth victim
was an 11 year old girl well he wasn't
going after him based on their jobs just
how they looked how they looked and what
the damn opportunity was yeah um so 11
year old Mary Ramey she was actually
dragged out of her house like she was in
bed in the middle of the night they she
was dragged out of her house dragged
into a wash
raped and stabbed through the ear all
victims black um no okay just saw the
early ones were and then later on that
was a couple of white women I still
think he's black
I think this is a black guy a couple
people saw him but there's no consensus
because some people said it was like
maybe a black guy and some said it was
maybe a white guy like maybe he was
super light-skinned I was Gilly sure
yeah it's kisses you know just
statistically serial killers prey within
there they go after their own ethnic yes
so going after a black one would be
natural for him yeah although like I
said later that he did kill a cop well
he's opening waiting horizons yeah he's
like well if I can kill them and I can
kill his white people too yeah yeah
that's all this so yeah so this was an
11 year old girl she was killed on
August 30th 1885 now the next two
victims were actually a couple and
Gracie Vance and her boyfriend orange
Washington this happened September 28
1885 both of them were found with their
heads bludgeoned and the newspaper said
that Gracie was quote almost beaten into
a jelly to him which yuck that's pretty
girls must it must have been a blunt
object yeah like a bat axe or the
backside of the axe back side of the axe
here because I feel like a lot of ex
murderers actually use like the blunt
side of the axe more than yeah because
it doesn't stick it stuck in and any
kind of fight you ever seen videos of
any kind of fight blunt-force trama a
lot more effective than [ __ ] not that
then penetration you can see a guy punch
another guy in the face it takes him
down instantly and then you see another
video of a guy taking take a knife and
stab a guy seven or eight times in the
guy's run away right yeah it doesn't
have well like a sharp objects don't
have stopping well in plus because like
you're not really working with much area
like on the blade unless you like get
him in like right in the [ __ ] middle
of the heart the first time or like
right in the first movies where you see
I'm not gonna work you stab the dude
into these they just fall there's no
stopping power there yeah you need some
blunt object
hammer a big big face like a rubber
mallet that would be even better than a
damn hammer that used to drive nails
actually because guys used that we know
all about that from the show and the
research the hammer pops into the skull
and gets caught yeah so really it's
better to just use a damn rubber [ __ ]
mallet you use for bodywork that would
be more effective than damage probably
would be yeah bigger bigger boom it'll
knock you out well yeah yeah knock you
out and then you can work a [ __ ]
over when they're unconscious really
want to do just ask Dennis and Dee I'm
just talking about in terms of just a
fight yeah all fights are resolved with
stopping power okay guns are fists or
whatever it's blunt-force trauma you
render somebody unconscious as quickly
as you can to end the fight that's all
it is yeah so you know don't go for that
knife [ __ ] yes movies well like I
said I feel like a lot of killers
probably use knives not because they
think that they are better at killing
people but because it's more like
phallic it's a phallic thing and I think
it's also just kind of a it's a more
intimate weapon and I think it's
mystique yeah it's that like slaying
dragons and it's scary it's scary but
it's unless you slip somebody's throat
even that takes time for them to [ __ ]
bleed out they'll lose blood pressure
quickly and lose consciousness quickly
but that you that's something that
doesn't happen in combat that's
something you do to it to a prisoner
yeah cut their throats it's just knives
aren't any good yeah you know they're
not a good weapon you know there when I
was in the army everybody carried I mean
on bayonets and Special Forces guy you
don't use that as the weapon well you
might need it for other [ __ ] just it's
just what you use for [ __ ] in a camp
right for cutting things you know I mean
and you know cutting string and setting
camp and fixing something or maybe
opening it up fish and cleaning fish and
small game you know you can use it for
that that's not a good weapon yeah so
the next two victims were both taken on
you know right buried like close in time
to one another on Christmas Eve of 18
85 these were two separate crimes
committed in different locations these
two women were white unlike all of his
other previous victims who have been
black the first of them was Susan
Hancock who was reported as one of the
most refined ladies in Austin okay and
the next one was EULA Phillips who was
17 both these women were both murdered
in their houses
Susan Hancock's head was kind of chopped
in two just before midnight on Christmas
Eve also it looked like the killer had
stuck something into her right ear that
went all the way into her brain perhaps
an ice pick or some some weapon of that
nature
yeah EULA Phillips was killed on the
very early morning hours of Christmas
Day I got a question what's that these
crime scenes does it look like a
struggles taking place or does he just
beat him up time up and then kill him or
disease he's not actually sure because
they're in their beds generally so I'm
guessing he's coming into the middle of
the night where they're sleeping yeah
creeping in and cutting them
just like the Axman of New Orleans did
like they're there weren't like a lot of
signs of struggle and those because he
would just come in in the middle of the
night and just like bash you in the head
while you're sleeping and you didn't
even know what the [ __ ] was going so
okay so he's not so much into the damn
suffering and the torture part of it and
yeah I mean he did rape some of them and
he did like drag them some of them out
of the house to rape them and like then
kill them later yeah um but it does seem
like a lot of them he just kind of like
bashed him and that while they were
sleeping yeah kind of Sasson yeah and is
he raping him after they're dead perhaps
well now well EULA Phillips his last
victim she had been she was found in her
bed her head had also been crushed by an
axe now she had been raped presumably
while she was still alive you know I
mean yeah so interestingly in her case
they actually found that they that the
killer had like pinned her arm sound was
like these really big pieces of Tim
like I guess you know they were really
heaven he put them on there like she
could have moved or whatever yeah now
because of this that they weren't really
sure if maybe this was a different
killer because it it happened the same
night as one of the other ones but they
were only like a you know like an hour
or two apart so they thought maybe this
is a different person you know then
maybe they have a couple different
killers running around so that was kind
of that too because that was like a
factor that hadn't really turned up in
any of the other crimes like none of the
other women were restrained in any way I
guess you could say you know even though
she had been also been bashed in the
head with an axe so now as we said this
is even before the Jack the Ripper
murders [ __ ] started so it's like
they had nothing pretty much to go on
no fingerprinting no blood typing no
there was nothing like that so you know
and they couldn't even like really
conceive of one or more than one lunatic
like running around doing this kind of
[ __ ] pretty much all they could do was
like get some bloodhounds and like run
him around and shed the bloodhounds
didn't really it was not that much I'm
pretty sure that it was one yeah yeah so
um I do believe that they brought the
Pinkertons in on this case if I'm
remembering correctly yeah that was been
the premier law enforcement agency at
the time if he would call that at a law
enforcement agency they were do I said
it was a private they were mercenaries
yeah mercenary detective in Chicago yeah
this very good yeah they were the best
you can get at the time yeah yeah and
like I said I believe they were brought
in on this particular case now during
the course of the investigation such as
it was there were about 400 men arrested
at varying times for being the servant
girl Annihilator however none of them
were ever brought to trial because it
was never enough evidence to you know
keep any of them in custody now among
the people that were arrested were
Walter Spencer who was the boyfriend of
the first victim he actually went to
trial but was acquitted
only two days they also arrested the
husband of the last victim who was EULA
Phillips whose name was Jimmy Phillips
they also arrested the husband of the
second-to-last victim Susan Hancock
whose name was Moses Hancock what they
were trying to show to prove with EULA's
husband was that since there was a
couple of different factors that maybe
he was like the first quote/unquote
copycat killer although they didn't have
that term at the time and he was just
like he wanted to get rid of his wife
because apparently she was like super
beautiful there are a couple of pictures
of her she was a very good-looking woman
um you know well she was only 17 but you
know what I mean and apparently the
rumor was that she'd been like sleeping
around and maybe he was pissed off about
it and maybe he was looking for a way to
get rid of her and here was a way he
could do it and then make it look like
the servant girl Annihilator had done it
unlikely but yeah so they were just
saying that was a possibility but you
know he was never convicted of anything
like that
he actually well he did actually at
first he got sentenced to seven years
but then like the the judge overturned
it because they said you know there's
not enough a no that's just that was a
damn moral panic yeah so now one of the
intriguing theories about who the
serpent girl Annihilator might have been
was that he may have been a Malaysian
cook whose last name is not known he's
only known by his first name of Maurice
now he worked at the Perl House Hotel in
Austin he had allegedly told friends and
acquaintances of his that he was going
by ship to London and he left town in
January 1886 and that was only a few
weeks after the servant girl Annihilator
murders ended now interestingly if he
did indeed go to London then the Jack
the Ripper murders started not that long
after he got there so some people have
speculated that it could be the same guy
that the servant girl Annihilator in
Jack the Ripper might be the same person
they just do that over and over they do
there's like four or five guys that
could have been the
Ripper yeah because people I mean
surprisingly pathetic so I go and go
back and forth Ripper was a white dude
yeah this town yeah I think he was well
yeah because like I said I think that
although this does kind of check out
what this guy may have been the
Annihilator yeah because he started off
with black girls and then that era he
just would have been a non-white guy
yeah who had access to them easier I
would think yeah yeah maybe like less
access to white women but then he builds
up his [ __ ] courage he says [ __ ] it
I'm going for these white women anyway
yeah yeah I mean could could have been
something like that but it's less likely
what's more likely says light-skinned
black guy maybe he was a guy that he
could maybe pass maybe not you're a
white person but maybe for another
ethnicity he was a guy who was
considered to be black in his day who
had a lot of white ancestry maybe his
mother was white maybe his dad was white
and then he's not an aspire to white
women alright so he started off with the
black once we're in his day and time
that's where he would have belonged okay
cuz it was all segregated in [ __ ] right
and then he goes suck that nah I'm gonna
go out for these white women I'm gonna
go for the white women so he goes kills
them yeah because you know I know that
we have a lot of lot of regular
listeners to actually kind of know how
serial killers work but you know just in
case you're not really a regular
listener serial killers are a damn it
they're there what he called and they're
uh they're a sexual orientation there's
a sexual orientation she knows exactly
what I'm thinking there's a sexual
orientation and the baseline is to be
oriented towards your own race if you
start off with black girls and then go
on to white girls then that means you're
both of those races that's just what I'm
saying
yeah and in those days a mixed race
person would have been considered
non-white ie black so they start with
the black ones yeah but biologically
he's black and white so he goes to the
white ones too that's what happened yeah
I see that's an 80% chance it's not
definite but
because you know humans aren't aren't
robots it's just the statistics yeah to
tist eclis this is a light-skinned black
guy yeah yeah and that's just That's not
me saying this this is what an FBI
profile will tell you yeah I know I read
all the books that they did they would
say yeah probably light-skinned black oh
yeah yeah another thing too is that you
know people that say that this Maurice
person was at least the servant girl
Annihilator if not both you know him and
Jack the Ripper was that three of the
victims were found in the same
neighborhood as the hotel where he
worked so they thought that was a little
fishy but like I said not only candidate
to convict him yeah he's a candidate but
statistically yeah the book is gonna say
he's light-skinned black yeah now there
is another author named Shirley Harrison
who also thinks that Jack the Ripper and
the servant girl Annihilator might be
the same person but he doesn't but she
doesn't think that it's the same person
is in this other thing it was named
Maurice she thinks that it's a guy named
James Maybrick who was from Liverpool
and was a cotton merchant um now she
thinks this because apparently he had
some journals that were found after he
died that said that he had killed
prostitutes he had actually like signed
a page of his journal with the name Jack
the Ripper I don't know if he was just
[ __ ] around or whatever he actually
ended up dying in May 1889 they think
that he either died of arsenic or
strychnine poisoning which was given to
him by his wife they think yes now he
died in May 1889 which was not that long
after the last Jack the Ripper murder
and again like after the servant girl
Annihilator murders because those ended
in 1885 I'm not buying it because there
have been many murderers that have
claimed to be Jack the Ripper
true I mean they had a guy he might just
be a fanboy they had an American guy
here or no they had a guy here killed in
America that was I believe from England
or Scotland I don't remember and as they
were pulling the damn lever to drop him
down you know I mean through the gallows
to hang him he goes oh by the way I'm
jacked up yeah we talked
yeah the audience don't may not know
about that so there been a lot of guys
that have claimed to be Jack the Ripper
but I don't [ __ ] believe that [ __ ]
yeah and that's the and the the
frustrating thing is that while one of
them very well maybe cuz someone's got
to be you know yeah but at this stage
we'll probably never find out it's like
there's no way unless you can get a
[ __ ] time machine I don't blue the
jacks I don't believe Jack the Ripper
was ever caught no I don't think he was
ever caught I don't think it was no I
don't think I don't think they ever got
that dude into custody yeah I think he
stopped killing that's what I think
happened to him yeah and then it never
caught him Auri and he's not killing for
one reason or another he may have just
stopped killing because he lost his
[ __ ] gusto for it or he died did
disease was sucking bad back then well
yet people in mortality rates
particularly not in Whitechapel yeah he
might have gotten sick and died and
right after you know so you just don't
know but no they never had that dude in
custody now there are a lot of guys that
were trying to [ __ ] claim that mantle
of Jack the Ripper
that would've that was among killers
that was the big one you might as well
just say well I'm not a minor demon I'm
[ __ ] Satan himself well like you said
that might have tied in with why the
thames torso murderer left that one
torture in Whitechapel
he was an admirer was like he was trying
to like get respect you know there man
I'm sure they admired that notoriety and
that fame that they had in the damn
media I mean all of these [ __ ]
eventually can't resist it I mean Dennis
could have got away with this [ __ ] but
well I had to cash in my cool credits
enough [ __ ] they'd have to [ __ ]
eventually they'd have to eventually
come forth and [ __ ] try to claim
their crown yeah you know I mean or they
seem to but you know and if they can't
claim they're wrong then they're gonna
claim somebody else's and I think that's
what happened with the Ripper
I think the Ripper died yeah and then
other dudes started coming forward you
know after they were caught Santa
I'm the Ripper that's me that was me now
it's just like oh it's like [ __ ]
Henry Lee Lucas in like all this like
cereal because who actually kill people
but then they like take about take
credit for like [ __ ] and
yeah like this there's no way that they
could have done Henry Lee Lucas a
[ __ ] spin a yarn all day long he
confessed to like 200 murders he's
somebody my Godzilla that dude's a
[ __ ] liar maybe killed two or three
two or three one of them a damn robbery
they they were they weren't they weren't
that type of serial killer they were
just he just like he just like to
confess tower yeah you like to confess
and he liked to [ __ ] him I think then he
I think well I I don't even think it was
just that I think it was also because he
enjoyed interfering with other people
with the investigation and then all the
attention and he got right they were
taking him out of prison I think he
thought it was hitting him all rides
everywhere and giving me donald's and
[ __ ] yeah well yeah I mean I guess if
you're in prison like forever just go
for ride it's got McDonald's yeah go
take me to the drive-thru give me that
back like that [ __ ] yeah got life anyway
I'll go find the body for you oh I must
have forgot where it was yeah I saw
videos of him coaching him was it over
here she was it was the body left over
there was she blonde yeah yeah I think
yeah yeah yeah sure now another theory
that actually came forward as far as I
know I saw it on the History Detectives
show that aired a few years ago they
think the servant girl Annihilator might
have been a young black man working in
downtown Austin he was also a cook he
was 19 years old and his name was Nathan
Elgin now as I said when the murders
occurred he was only 19 years old now in
18 February of 1886 which was only a
couple of months after the last servant
girl Annihilator murders he'd read he
was seen dragging a girl out of a bar
and assaulting her attempting to
sexually assault her and police shot him
and killed him huh so interestingly
there were no serve more servant girl
Annihilator murders after that happened
that maybe the so yeah it's like it
seems like this is a younger guy he's a
kook he works in that area so maybe the
first victims were women that he knew
because they were coming over then what
about 16 when he was 19 but when he
started well it was only a year
only a year okay yeah that the murder
that's about prime time neither calling
in black yeah
Hammacher betty was more like biracial
yeah you might have been yeah which
nobody knows that I don't think there's
any pictures of him or anything that
means that that was [ __ ] that may have
bit him
yeah and like I said it's interesting to
me that he worked as a cook because the
first couple of victims were cooks also
yeah so I feel like he maybe started it
was kind of like a Silence of the Lambs
information book scene where it's like
he started with somebody that he knew or
saw and then started to like move out to
work to strangers that's a good one
that's probably that's it's likely so we
don't know for sure yeah but that seems
a lot more likely to be than that's
probably who it was you know what I mean
or was somebody like that yeah or
somebody like that again so servant girl
Annihilator never caught considered
America's first serial killer eight
murders mostly women but one man and one
eleven-year-old kid and like I said a
lot of people who try to tie it into
Jack the Ripper but I don't know if I
buy that because like I said yeah like I
said it's not impossible but I do feel
like everybody everybody that's done
that type of murder no matter where they
live if it's a woman could have got our
boat and gone to London and killed
people there and [ __ ] like that it's
like yeah they could have but it's like
there's no way a big good heaven did God
haven't dead right and like I said at
this point that will probably never
prove it and in a way I feel like that's
probably why I mean I'm fascinated with
like these old like nineteenth-century
murders and stuff like that even though
they're very frustrating because you
know they're never gonna get solved I
mean it's know everything and based on
everything about the Ripper case he
seemed to hate already [ __ ]
prostitutes yeah that's what that seemed
to be mostly the target yeah I think he
picked up syphilis from him okay and
then it was like taking her banish
taking revenge on him and the reason why
he stopped is because he died from that
syphilis that's yeah that's a
possibility I think at that's a
possibility
that's right think it's likely that yes
because that does sound like if
somebody's like some dude is like
unhinged and then he's dying and also
has some kind of maybe some kind of like
misplaced guilt about going to
prostitutes or something like that and
is already kind of like self-loathing
because of doing that and then they pick
up a disease that's going to kill them
yeah then they're going to like parley
that blame out on them on to other
people yeah he's gonna kill a few of
them and then he's gonna skirt off into
the darkness and die that damn disease
and then you'll never hear you he'll
never get caught once there's dead and
that dude wasn't it wasn't a rich dude
anyway you know I mean he was he's a
poor guy I kind of feel like he probably
lived around the area because area I
mean I don't think he stood out all that
much no he lived in that area and then
once he died he was the kind of dude
that when he died people are like ugh
good riddance
yeah they buried that dude and he tried
to forget about it they tried to forget
about him quickly and they never
suspected that dude yeah that's that's
what I think happened probably he just
died and like he died ignominious died
of syphilis right circumstances
somewhere cuz I don't think he had sex
with any of them girls that he killed or
girls they were old hags well they were
women yeah yeah milfs yeah but when you
see the pictures of a man they were so
ravaged by their lifestyle and
everything I think one of them was 50
but she looked like she's about 80 well
yeah there was some luck that was a hard
life back it's my life now but you can
imagine how much worse it was bad AM
Grimm's fairytale that's what I mean she
look like she it's like the Whitechapel
was like there's like if there was
[ __ ] like rivers of [ __ ] and the [ __ ]
it's like there was everyone was disease
looking like man only a superhero could
rock up on that well not like it's not
like they had a lawn it was ugly choice
yeah was it no you know what I mean I
don't think sex heavy innit sex hey
anything you do what the [ __ ] can
Whitechapel murders I think it was
vengeance and he'd see these old hags
there's a [ __ ] like you they gave me
this [ __ ] terminal disease and he
just [ __ ] butchered him yeah I think
that's probably didn't seem too sexual
I mean think of it yeah he didn't really
seem sexual the like I said it seemed
more rage big rage it was rage yeah and
it was on the spot
you know there's only one of them that
was in like her room and even that one
and that one was the most brutal of all
right and then and then like well there
is the [ __ ] cannibalistic
angle but that might have been [ __ ]
too that could might have been a damn
calves kidney yeah said to the cop yeah
baby he was just trying to make it sound
like I might have been somebody else
that did that yeah I don't know but yeah
so I guess we're probably way past the
halfway point at this stage so I guess
we will take a break right now and when
we come back we will discuss a couple
more kind of a little bit shorter cases
we're going to talk about the Denver
strangler and we're going to talk about
Alfred nap more cases of serial killers
from the 19th century we'll be back in
just a few minutes
you love true crime I love true crime
and I've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume three is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
Caddy murders the carry babies case the
Frog Boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain volume three is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
what to do amazing
what you doing you're just standing off
at the wall you visited Dennis
oh there's been
yeah
you keeping an eye on him in case he
does something bad yeah
you can't escape and where's Pookie
there she is always sleeping on the back
just in the Midland of living room floor
yeah is that what you're doing look at
her little back feet the back feet out
of the best part she just leaves a ball
suspended and now she's looking at me
like she hasn't no idea why I'm filming
her she's like what this is not weird in
the slightest I don't know what your
problem is
yeah yeah you do you Pookie that's right
yeah yeah oh it's so relaxing it's a
relaxing conspiratorial podcast proudly
presents the strange realities
conference injury
come join us for one day of
presentations on the paranormal of live
music and night featuring Tim the north
of rise and fall of the Flat Earth
theory Joshua kuchen alien hybrid Lord
Amar'e pushing the limits of reality
what really happened
Timothy Renard Pennsylvania Wildman and
added to the lineup Marc Anthony Wyatt
Cornish legends and UFO sighting Zach
hunt presentation of this book unwrapped
followed by a live recording of the
conspiratorial podcast more speakers and
music acts to be announced October 19
2019 si our nationís info at WWE Champ
Car $40 at the door 30 bucks presale
[Music]
all right we are back from the break
talking about 19th century murders old
timey serial killers yeah these two
cases are intertwined so we're gonna
kind of do them all kinda in one story
yeah [ __ ] over with
yeah cuz these are technically two
different cases but there is like a
victim in common brah you know what I
mean so I'm just gonna like tie this
together yeah so the first thing we're
gonna talk about and this one it's it's
interesting because it's very very
difficult to find like much of any
information about this it seems like
this is one of those kind of Forgotten
serial killer cases this is the case of
the Denver strangler now this is another
guy presumably it's a guy who was never
caught unidentified serial killer
responsible for at least three murders
that happened in 1894 and suspected of a
few others maybe to others that happen
like a few years later and there was
like a handful of other ones that they
think might have been him as well but no
one has ever been caught for them there
have been a couple of you know different
people arrested for various things but
no one's ever been convicted of any of
these now the first victim was named
Lena tapper or Tapei she was a French
prostitute she had been living in
Minnesota but then moved to Denver as
the mistress of a guy named Richard de
Maudie now both her and Richard were in
this sort of I'm not sure exactly what
it is but it was this kind of like
secret society like I guess like a lot
of French and immigrants were in it or
something like that but it was called
the maca root which is the French word
for pimp or procurer okay so it's kind
of like I don't know just like an eyes
wide shut type situation where it's just
kind of like a secret sex cult or
something like that it's like a pimp
cult
I guess it is but yeah so apparently
they were both involved in this you know
whether that played into the murders I'm
not really sure but so on September 3rd
1894
Leena tapper was found choked to death
on her bed in Market Street in Denver
now the second victim was also a French
prostitute and also had ties to this
same group her name was Marie
Cantus wah now she was living with her
boyfriend Tony Sanders now she had
actually she was in her house she was
reading the paper and she had like
fallen asleep on her bed and then the
next day when someone came in the house
like looking for her or whatever they
found her choked to death on her bed hmm
someone had taken like a kind of a
chunky piece of cord or rope or
something like that and tied it like so
tight around her neck that it was like
buried into the flesh there were also
some finger marks like somebody tried to
strangle or manually and maybe couldn't
do it and so they did it with some guy I
guess so now she actually had like a bit
of money she was a poor or anything like
that but they only found 75 cents on her
at the time of her death so the
authorities at the time thought that
maybe it was just a robbery gone wrong
now at the time of her murder I don't
know if they initially like linked these
first two together even though they
happened like you know only a few weeks
apart but they arrested five different
dudes including her boyfriend the first
victims boyfriend whose name was Richard
Ahmadi they also arrested a guy that was
like a messenger that had been in the
house and a cook that had been in her
house now they had apparently both been
in the house when she got murdered but
none of them said they heard anything
which I thought was a little fishy but
whatever but they didn't have enough
evidence to hold either one of them
now the third victim was another
immigrant she was also a sex worker she
was Japanese
she was 24 24 years old and her name was
Kiku oh Yama now she actually came to
the US through Chicago at the time of
the World's Columbian Exposition
there she met a guy named Mei Yama who
became her boyfriend and they moved to
Denver in late 1893 now a few days
before she got murdered apparently the
cops had raided a bunch of like [ __ ]
houses in the area and I guess she was
either working there or she knew like
some women that were working there now
she now her boyfriend actually was able
to kind of like negotiate like the
release of all the girls that got
arrested but then there was like this
saloon keeper who was in on it and he
was like trying to shake him down for
money and all this other kind of crap so
the boyfriend and you know the and the
saloon keeper or the girlfriend the
saloon keeper they kind of had this big
argument about it so they're speculating
that maybe there was some kind of reason
there because there had been this whole
sting with the prostitution and he had
asked for money and she got mad about it
and argued with him and maybe he killed
her they don't really know so there's
trauma inside the pimp game yeah that
seems like a lot of that going on around
this time period
now Kiku oh Yama was last seen on
November 13th in the evening she was
actually hanging out with some of her
friends and then she returned to her
house later in the evening closed the
curtains and was thought to have just
gone to bed like normal her boyfriend
had gone out for a walk and when he came
back he found her lying on the bed with
a towel wrapped very tightly around her
neck now when he found her she was still
alive but just barely
what were you gonna say no no okay I'm
letting this all play out imagine oh
yeah go ahead so her boyfriend runs in
realizes that she's still alive you know
unties the towel from around her neck
and then he ran across the street to get
help you know so this other woman comes
over for helps a cop you know down the
street like here's a man comes for help
but you know to help them and stuff like
that but by the time they get back over
there Kiku oh yama is dead now in this
case it looked like a very large
struggle had taken place
the sheets were all you know rocked up
there was blood everywhere
there was another towel that was like
wet and it was laying like on the sink
or the wash stand or whatever and it
looked like the killer had you know
ransacked the place like he had gone
through all the drawers and stuff like
that maybe looking for money they had
they also couldn't find the keys to
either the front door or the back door
of the house so presumably the killer
took those as well
this victim also had finger marks on her
windpipe and had a bruise on her
forehead which was non-lethal so they
think what happened was that the killer
came in and then like you know pulled
the towel like around her neck and then
they were struggling and then she fell
on the bed or whatever so they made a
bunch of arrests they arrested her
boyfriend they arrested a lot of her
friends who were prostitutes like the
other Japanese woman in the air and
stuff like that but again like after a
few days they had to release them all
because they had no evidence to hold
anyone now later on there were also a
couple of other murders that they
suspected might have been the work of
the same killer now this is pretty weird
right here there's this woman named
Julia vote I guess would be how you
pronounce that it's Bo ght she was
actually a medium and a clairvoyant and
she during the initial run of the
murders which was just the three
prostitutes like I said it happened over
a pretty brief period of time I believe
it was only nine or ten weeks she told
the police that she had gone into a
trance and that the spirits had told her
what the Denver strangler looked like
right so so there's this whole thing but
several like a couple years after the
canonical murders in October of 1898 she
was found dead in her apartment lying on
the floor with a towel tied around her
neck just like the third victim had been
so they're not really sure if the
strangler heard about her and was like
oh [ __ ]
she really does know what I look like
coz she's for real psychic and decided
to kill her or if he was just like
covering all the bases I don't know
this this is my theory are you ready for
this sure mediums and psychics of this
era which is the late 1800s sometimes
we're hookers well I I think you're kind
of dealing with just another hooker
maybe this is some kind of drama in the
pimp game that's what I think's going on
this isn't a serial killer it's not a
series well technically it is because I
think it's a robbery yeah and he did
seem to look for money it's more like
robbery yeah because there doesn't seem
to be a sexual motive in either one of
these murders or you need three of these
murders yeah it's somebody in the damn
prostitution game that is murdering
prostitutes for the money I'm gonna say
it's female do you think I think it's a
girl or maybe two or three girls hmm
jealous hookers it does kind of it
interests me that a couple of the
victims like the the second and third
victim were found with finger marks on
their neck but then they were like
strangled with something else there's no
gray or rotted and well so that's
interesting to me because it almost
seems like the killer was trying to
strangle them with their hands but they
couldn't do it right so then they found
something else it's a couple of girls
either that or it's like a really wimpy
man I think it's a couple of girls might
have been those Japanese girls maybe
they were taken into custody like some
of them were that were friends of the
third victim yeah maybe they were
shinobi hahaha go back and watch our
ninja [ __ ] over there ninja say yeah
yeah well yeah well they never caught
the pursue they very well could have
been it again gang of gang of [ __ ]
girls working as prostitutes girl gang
with a bunch of [ __ ] player hate
involved in that [ __ ] making all this
damn money prettier than he's not
[ __ ] kicking back and paying her dues
and buh buh you know what I mean they're
good yeah that's what this is that's
honestly never occurred to me because
well because I never jumped the
conclusion that a serial killer is a
woman because ninety
times out of 100 at the man yeah but the
thing is is that but although says
having 100% of the time really when
you're talking about men as serial
killers the motive is sex yeah not
robbery it's real all right and there
doesn't seem to be any [ __ ] signs of
sex or torture or any kind of fetishes
I'm really there yeah you're like pro
hits it's kind of like a situation where
a couple of girls go in there and they
corner her annecy you better pay up but
the move uh and you know I mean and
there's some kind of you know some kind
of discussion and you're like [ __ ] you
know that you owe us this money for
buhbuh buhbuh blah and then get her you
know I mean they [ __ ] jump on her and
choke her out with like all these angels
yeah and then they fail so then they
give me that towel and then they start
you know yeah give me that rope yeah
that's what this looks like to me I'm
just saying it doesn't look like
interested and not sexually motivated
murders this the motive is money and I
don't think it's girls I think it might
be the happen even though all the
suspects are been you know all this
that's the patriarchy doing this [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] sexist that's sexism
they're looking for men so they're just
arresting like a man thanks to the time
most times it's men but the thing is
those of the Mystics if a man starts
knocking off women in secession the
motive is sex where's the rape yeah
there's not even really any mutilation
there isn't even a mutilation so there's
no torture there's no sexual graph these
are just in their houses there's no sign
of any kind of sexual gratification
happening to these women
not that I'd there's nothing like I said
there's not a huge amount of information
they're not laid out in display there
doesn't seem to be any kind of rape or
torture that's the signature of a
[ __ ] serial killer this is more like
mafia hits yeah alright and badly done
mafia hits as if somebody lacks strength
its hookers yeah
hookers hooker gang a gang of hookers
keeping another good band name yeah yeah
a hookers hook again the other girls in
line over something there's
something about money yeah something
about owning money maybe they had some
kind of plan opening it up some kind of
clandestine brothel and they're stealing
money and they gotta check each other
and you say the first one was involved
in some kind of damn cult of the first
two were first three war it was some
kind of not sure exactly what it was
like I said it was some kind of like
secret society like I said I got the
impression there make some guys watch
shut there's any connection between
those two though the first two victims
and then the Japanese girls I don't
think so I mean it was probably like an
indirect I mean they it was they were
all from the same area and they were all
sex workers so I assumed that they were
all it's in the name it's some kind of
upstart madam with a couple of and she
was like trying to eliminate yeah a
petition or try to get them in her team
and that [ __ ] didn't work out some kind
of upstart madam with a complex machete
with a couple of her girls yeah doing
this might have just been those [ __ ]
are making all the money go killer let's
go so you got a team of who is that what
am i be knocking them off knocking off
the competition and then taking them
it's something dumb like that yeah
doesn't strike me as a male serial
killer the crime scenes just don't speak
to me that way
yeah true like I said they're not super
splashy
they're not splashy there doesn't seem
to be any sexual motive yeah hmm
interesting
but yeah so so this one that they were
like I said they're not entirely sure if
it's the same person or not but she was
interestingly she was a she said she was
a clairvoyant and she had reported to
police that spirits had told her what
they look like what did she say he look
I'm not I don't know um but um but yeah
so she was actually murdered in the same
fashion I'm Jon bet you a hooker too she
might have been yeah now in 1903 there
was another one that they think might
have been part of the same series even
though this was nine years later this
woman's name was Mabel Brown she was
also found dead in her bedroom on the
same Street Market Street her hands had
been tied with a pair of suspenders a
handkerchief was put in her mouth and
her throat had strangulation marks much
likes the
women and she was also found lying on
her bed had been strangled
so no signs of rape no signs of struggle
no even though like I said there's a
pretty big gap in there that looks like
a nine-year gap oh nine years now this
woman she lived in the same street I
don't know if she was a prostitute or
not alike it didn't really say like I
said there's not a huge amount of
information on these murders they seem
to normally like they seem to have
generally been forgotten about that
sounded like something some kind of mob
thing maybe now there were Bob would
have [ __ ] eliminated the body she
never would have been found yeah yeah so
there were also um you know some people
have speculated that the Denver
strangler might have been responsible
for a few other murders
there was also there was a murder of a
woman named Mary Eckhart that happened
in Cincinnati in 1894 now actually
someone was hanged for that and that's
the person that we're gonna talk about
in the next little segment so not really
sure about that there was also a woman
named Minnie Celt who was murdered in
May of 1894 in New York City and there
was one named Josie Bennett that
happened in June of 1894 that was in
Buffalo New York the time those were you
know the the modus operandi was similar
enough that they thought that maybe this
person was like time has stretched out
too long you know if you asked me yeah I
mean these are these are separate cases
yeah these are separate offenders if you
ask me the first ones I think if I've
already identified the other ones that
we're just talking about I think these
might be isolated incidents but go ahead
maybe now they have a few suspects for
who they think this might be the first
suspect is Richard Ahmadi who was the
lover of the first victim wait a minute
connecting all the way back down to the
first one yeah okay um you know so he
was in this like weird pimping sex
Society or whatever he did actually get
charged initially with the death of the
first woman Lena tapper even though the
evidence was circumstantial and like I
said he actually was convicted at first
but then his conviction was overturned
later on now the prosecution
the trial actually brought forth two
witnesses both of whom said that they
had witnessed Lena tapper struggling
with Richard de ma date like through
like they saw him through the window
like that them that they were struggling
apparently this was on the day that she
like previous to her dying also the
prosecuting attorney produced a check
that had been written by Richard de
Maudie
he seemed to have been trying to bribe
the judge into releasing him he did get
acquitted like I said he was convicted
at first but then you know the judge
overturned it after the trial was over
he moved to Brazil and was apparently
never heard of again now there was
another suspect named Frank Roche he was
a french-canadian roustabout and he
actually lived on her near Market Street
hold on one second what's that so the
very first suspect was only linked to
the first murder but none of the other
ones yeah but he was in that sex cult
that the second victim was also in and
mate was he it was he there was he
available to do the murder these
subsequent murders I'm not really sure
like I said they only put him on trial
for the first one yeah that means he
could have done the other ones no I'm
fine if to make this one big serial
killer type of situation you need to
find one [ __ ] this links to
everybody yeah that's the thing okay
wait so this guy Frank Roche as I said
he was a french-canadian roustabout
lived near Market Street now he actually
was arrested because he matched the
description of a man seen running away
from the murder scene of the third
victim
kiku Aoyama he was like running away
from her house shortly after the murder
he was also associated with the weird
like the macaron sex cult but police
didn't really have enough evidence to
hold him either so he was actually never
tried never convicted now there was
another guy named H Miller I don't know
what his first name was he's only just
that it's HML or he was an Italian man
now he was actually
what ended up happening and I actually
saw the original newspaper report about
this on November 18th 1894 he came into
the house of a woman that apparently he
knew her name was Marie vendor s they
had a fight and then he started
strangling her now he like had his hands
around her neck so tight that she
couldn't like scream or talk or anything
like that but evidently she struggled
and she managed to get away now you know
someone called the cops the cops showed
up and he was had a razor to her throat
like he was just about ready to cut it
right hmm now this is interesting to me
that it's like they pretty much caught
the guy in the middle of doing something
like that and yet they said well we
don't think he's the Denver strangler we
just think he's a guy with a bad temper
well that might be there Mike yeah you
think this is a time when you think this
this is a time and place when a
[ __ ] might have to smack a [ __ ]
we're not talking about the kind and
gentle [ __ ] society we have now there
might have been a lot of dudes that
manhandled well I mean I'm sure most
people back in those days you know what
I mean you get out of line you gonna
[ __ ] get get punched in the mouth
with a F in the mouth for the mouth yeah
I mean that you know so that may not
necessarily mean mean you're a serial
killer yeah you have to have one guy
that connects all these [ __ ]
homicides together yeah to have a serial
killer now I'm not seeing that so far
yeah
now the next two suspects were actually
kind of friends or acquaintances or I
guess their names were Victor Mancha Roe
and Alphonse
lemare now apparently they had done this
is kind of funny but I think they had
done time together in San Quentin for
various offenses and they each said that
the other one had confessed to the
Denver strangler murders you know it's
like Victor they were bitching et that's
what I mean it was like this total [ __ ]
fight like Victor was like 40 yeah and
his friend a quote-unquote friend
Alphonse
said oh when we were in prison together
he told me that he did that
and then when they would they
interviewed like [ __ ] Victor he's like
no it was actually Alphonse yeah he was
the one that confessed and did that show
yes so like I said I don't think they
really took either of these like [ __ ]
seriously some of those dudes being
locked up together over time start
[ __ ] they start kind of having this
relationship together it's kind of like
a married couple
those [ __ ] will start [ __ ] lying
and [ __ ] yeah I mean okay hey you
know each other but then they're
inseparable so that's probably what that
show I feel like this is definitely this
project like it was kind of like really
read about well I mean Alphonse did you
know like a few days after the murder of
the Japanese girl he did say yeah I
killed all of them and I'm gonna kill
some more here at the time that's what I
mean like I don't know you know what I
mean he was a sailor he was in Denver at
the time he was in dead Bertha's yeah so
you know what I mean
so he was there but then the other one
says but then the other one says so like
I said this this this old [ __ ] fight I
don't know it could have been one of
them I have no idea no it sounds
unlikely whoever killed those Japanese
girls knew those girls yeah to gain
access well yeah because like I said I I
feel like you know and again forgive me
there's really not a lot of information
about the about this case cuz it seems
like it's totally forgotten about but
none of them say that there was any sign
of like forced entry or anything I do so
maybe it was somebody that they let in
that first two or three of them that we
were talking about I think that's girls
doing that maybe I think it's a hooker
fight Oh
hooker fight for it to be a male I'll
write and to be a male serial killer
there has to be some kind of a sexual
motive that's what they do
yeah there's serial rapists he just
happened to kill the victim yeah well I
don't really see that in the crime scene
that's true like I said you seem just
like sex isn't the motive they seem very
workmanlike yeah it's
girls yeah and he said that there were
multiple different attempts to strangle
them which means that they lack strength
that's kind of what I was when I was
reading it that's what struck me about
it that's girls that there was
fingerprints on there and there was like
a towel wrapped her and almost like they
tried it and then that's it least two
girls trying to overpower another one
yeah probably shaking him down for money
yeah because like I said at least two of
the crime-scene yeah Benny get the money
and then a silencer by choking around
killing her yeah that's what's happening
it's fast cuz a hooker can be a thief
too and if you're gonna [ __ ] steal
then sometimes you have to kill a [ __ ]
to [ __ ] cover your tracks uh-huh even
though you just made like even bigger
tracks thinking of the time and the
people that we're talking about yeah I
mean that's it's it's it's hookers it's
hooker remember our time I bomb on bomb
violence yeah yes this is whole vibe
[Laughter]
okay so remember when I was talking
about the other murders that you know
people have speculated that might be the
Denver strangler and remember I talked
about this one victim named Mary Eckhart
who was killed in Cincinnati Ohio
okay well the guy that was actually
convicted of her murder is another
serial killer and we know who this one
is unlike all the other [ __ ]
we've talked about on this show this is
Alfred nap also known as the Hamilton
strangler now he is responsible for
killing at least five women and girls
between 1894 and 1902 okay so they're
gonna try to [ __ ] link Albert Knapp
to these Molly well not not to the
canonical ones but there were some that
were kind of on the fringes that they
thought were kind of similar he was
convicted of one of those or he or they
think that he did one of those this year
not so much the other ones now he was
actually old he was executed but he was
only executed as far as I know it
of one murder which was that of his
third wife so he was actually originally
from Indiana now when he was five years
old and again here's the head injury he
got kicked in the head by a horse
now he was another one that seems like
he was kind of like bad from the
beginning or from when he was kicked by
the horse I'm sure but he seemed like he
was spending a lot of time in and out of
prisons
mostly for sexual assault beating women
up things like that um interestingly he
was also a devout member of the Church
the fourth Christian Church he knew who
God was yeah we see Cain would probably
appreciate this because you kind of did
that same kind of crap he was also in
something called the Christian Endeavor
society where much like in a lot of
serial killer cases people like he
seemed some nice
well they Commission this nice quiet guy
they compartmentalize [ __ ] I guess so
yeah this is his dark secret going out
and [ __ ] raping and killing a hoe
although this guy was unusual in that he
killed some of his wives as well okay
okay so he was killing people at home
and abroad right yeah which you don't
usually see it's like funny what's funny
about these Victorian murderers is that
they did like to do all that keeping it
in the family and killing family members
poisoning people and marrying a [ __ ]
and poison her and then marrying another
woman poison her they liked that there's
something weird about him Victorians
were messed up Victorians are you
thinning y'all are listening from the
afterlife it just must had something to
do with just the the society in the
scene of the time people weren't quite
as atomized as they are today they
weren't as individual they were a bunch
of family groups so if you're gonna kill
somebody chances are you knew him you're
related to him yeah maybe that's kind of
what it was you know I mean a lot of
difference in this society of the
true so if you evolve into a serial
killer back in the 1800s chances are you
were gonna be some woman poisoning
husbands or some husband killing long
secessions of wives yeah
some of them use poison as well yeah a
lot of them just were trotting him in
the tub remember we had him drown yeah
so there's like some [ __ ] out of the
[ __ ] Disney haunted house man yeah
okay with the damn woman with that axe
you know that I mean till death do us
part that damn way they [ __ ] were and
I guess cuz they I guess cuz strangers
didn't interact as much in the 1800s
maybe yeah I suppose so serial killers
evolved in that way
yeah we just you know like love the one
you're with but kill yeah although to be
honest that's usually not so much serial
killers because serial killers tend to
rape kill strangers yeah but most
murders that are not committed by serial
killers are people that the victim you
know family or they know him right yeah
so maybe this is just what it was yeah
um well because people you know I mean
obviously they give you reason so the
most likely most likely during the
Victorian era would have been black
widows and guys [ __ ] poison and wives
yeah yeah and like I said a lot of it
seemed to be magical as well yeah like
we just need the inheritance but like
we're gonna lose the farm let's like
poison some of the kids writer I don't
like this [ __ ] I don't want to divorce
her cuz then I'll lose everything I'll
look bad so I'll kill her yeah get the
damn money and then I'll marry another
one yeah and then a few months I'm sick
of it I'm sick of this one now so I'm
gonna kill this one and get the damn
money and the women were doing the same
thing yeah what does that guy think what
was up with that it's like everybody
just seemed like a Cynthia but they were
sick us life was much harder I guess and
like they just didn't put up with anyone
[ __ ] I suppose I don't know what it was
well you could get away with it friends
if that
there and it was a harsh existence that
there wasn't a medium like a media so I
think these people were basically
ignorant by today's standards I didn't
know much about human behavior so they
were almost kind of like at the level of
children killing each other yes me cuz
you can just look at the products and
the writings of the time they were I
don't want to call them back yeah they
were kind of backwards by today's
standards yeah I don't think that's yeah
them backwards yeah kind of backwards
about is this so what would they know
and when and how does a backwards person
commit a crime you know I mean with this
I want me to get it they'll never know a
little kid
well the ironic thing about some of the
poisoning ones that we were talking
about is that if they had only killed
one or two people probably they would
never have been caught it's only because
they killed so many well they weren't us
that a pattern started to emerge yeah
they weren't they weren't intelligent
yeah but you know I mean they were
thinking well I mean they've forgotten
about that it's like I'm gonna get away
with one two maybe even three but once
you're getting up to like 90 they're
like well I got away with ten of them so
they're you know you haven't caught me
yet come yeah don't think they have
stomach fever yeah right so how to
understand it in a way like they're just
keep pressing they're lucky when your
back to the [ __ ] when you when you're
on [ __ ] homicide nine and this you're
still not being suspected you'd be like
yeah they're pretty dumb I'm getting
away with this I must be smart
yeah I'm they'll never suspect me yeah
that's what they're doing probably they
have suspected me yet yeah and I mean
you should always bite you and they ask
them and you gotta like [ __ ]
seriously alright so returning to the
tale of Alfred nap now on December 21st
of 1903
Alfred nap apparently woke up that day
with a wild hair across his ass and he
was going to strangle his wife
Hana's to death damn like you do
sometimes you should just wake up and go
strangle that [ __ ] I'm gonna kill a
[ __ ] crazy that's how I'm gonna
do now while she was actually his third
wife so um he wakes up with this thought
in his head and he proceeds to do just
that had be more to it he strangles her
to death
he puts her in a box like stuffs her
body in a box nails the Box shut took
the body two miles to the Great Miami
River and dumped it in
nobody would ever recognize her when
they find her though right probably not
that's what he's thinking
so after that little stunt he goes to
Cincinnati to visit his sister Sadie he
stays there for a couple of days and
then suddenly tells his sister oh my
wife is missing I have to go look for
her so then he moves back to Hamilton
which I think was in Indiana then he
goes to Indianapolis now a couple you
know only like a week or two after that
like the second day of january of
nineteen Oh three or 1904 he meets this
other woman named Anna Mae gamble and he
married her just like a month later now
only a couple weeks after that he gets
arrested because I guess he's kind of
going around making a big [ __ ] deal
about oh I gotta find my first wife
she's she disappeared and stuff even
though he's married someone else
subsequently so I don't know how that
works with the bigamy laws and
everything like that but he got arrested
on February 25th on suspicion that he
had killed his wife which he had so he
gets brought back to Hamilton and while
he's in police custody they don't even
really have to do all that much before
he says yeah I strangled her did I ever
in the river
damn so you know and then not only did
he confess to that he also said oh by
the way I also killed five other people
going back to 1894 so apparently and
this is what he told the police okay so
he had also killed a woman named Emily
who was killed in a lumberyard in June
of 1894 in Cincinnati the previously
mentioned Mary Eckert who was killed on
a street in Cincinnati in August of 1894
he also admitted that he had killed his
second wife Jenny Connors Knapp
she was also murdered on a street in
Cincinnati in August of 1894 and he also
killed a little girl named Ida gebhard
in Indianapolis in July of 1896 now they
think and you know he that's bad enough
but they police were also suspecting
that he may have killed other people as
well okay especially because he told
them yeah I'm kind of into like jumping
on little kids in the street and like
choking him so they think that he
probably killed more than he said why
didn't he confess to him I don't know I
don't know now the interesting thing
about this was that and I there's a book
about it and I can't member exactly what
it's called but I think it's called like
America's first celebrity serial killer
because apparently has forgotten as this
dude is today at the time like his trial
was a huge [ __ ] deal like and he was
like a celebrity with the capital C so
he's going to like they're taking over
the courtroom for his trial he's like um
you know chatting with the he was like
mr. personality and I mean he's like
chatting with the cops and it's like the
cops are being like super nice to him
because apparently he was like really
charming and she was like a job easy I
guess so yeah cuz he just was just like
yeah yeah I did it oh I did these other
ones too by the way that you can even
[ __ ] know yeah the cops are like
arrest credits Yeah right well we got we
solved like six murders in one afternoon
sweet so he didn't have an attorney so
his sister Sadie who he had been staying
with after he killed his third wife
acted as his defense attorney now they
said that while the trial was going on
that Alfred Knapp was acting
disinterested and so his sister is
sitting there like pleading on his
behalf
pretty much all they could argue at that
point since he had confessed all these
murders was that he was crazy yeah
so that you know he could be sent to a
hospital or something like that so she's
like desperately pleading it's like
please he's he's crazy we have like
mental illness in our family and stuff
like that and he's just like sitting
there looking up at the ceiling like
yeah like they said he didn't give a
[ __ ] at all cuz he knew he was gonna die
probably yes so now at the time of this
trial as I said even though he had
confessed all these murders they never
did find you know he said that he threw
that body into the you know in the box
and the river but they endeavored they
hadn't found it so there wasn't like a
lot of physical evidence for them to go
on however in March of nineteen Oh three
or 1904 they actually did find a woman's
nude body along a river in New Albany
Ohio and this was the body of his third
wife Hannah Knapp so now they have found
the body that bad for how long a long
time no well let's see four months okay
five months something like that all
right
so yeah she was wearing like all the
same jewelry and [ __ ] like that that
that he said that she had been wearing
when she went missing
hook witness and when he killed her so
yes so they did find her and so they
said hey we found your wife's body he's
like yeah well I told you then you know
I killed her and I threw in the river so
that's where she was that's where she
was so there was also all right though
there was this other thing that was
going on at the same time Alfred Knapp a
few days after they found the wife's
body
he gets subpoena to testify as a witness
in another trial of this other dude who
was named Joseph Roth now Joseph Roth
was suspected of assaulting I'm assuming
sexually assaulting two little girls
sisters named Hattie and Stella Mott sir
now the weird thing about it though was
that Joseph Roth like proclaimed his
innocence
however Alfred Knapp and Joseph Roth
looked really similar so some people
have suspected that Alfred Knapp was
actually the guy that sexually assaulted
those two girls and they mistook one for
the other because they looked so similar
you know what I mean so there was like a
lot of because he had like said oh I
like to jump on little kids and like
[ __ ] [ __ ] with him and stuff like
that so there might have been some of
that chick I went on to you so I thought
that was interesting that he got
subpoenaed at the trial but then like
the girls were like well they weren't
really sure because the two guys look so
similar so again since at the try at
Alfred Knapp's trial since all they
could do was say yeah he's a crazy he's
crazy because you know he had already
confessed to everything so he gets
convicted and sentenced to death pretty
much immediately his sister and mom are
at the trial and they just like freak
the [ __ ] out because apparently they
still thought he was great even though
he'd confessed all that crap but Alfred
was kind of stoic about it and I think
he only 3 years of 3 hours after he got
the sentence he was quoted as saying I
suppose it is all off with me like
that's all he said he's just like
whatever yeah so there was actually a
motion for a new trial I'm assuming that
didn't come from him that it might have
come from his family members but he
didn't really seem to give much of a
[ __ ] at all he just looked at the
ceiling the whole time that [ __ ] went
through yeah they did actually give him
a new trial because they thought like
during the first one there was like a
bunch of errors and [ __ ] like that that
happened like early in 1904 1905 but it
then later on it was later rejected now
later on the same year but you know
summer of that year cuz I guess they
didn't [ __ ] around back then once that
repeal was you know the appeal was
rejected there's like all right fries s
yeah so he got executed yeah in August
yeah wasn't like 1904-1905
wasn't like it is today where they gotta
be on death row for [ __ ] 20 years
it's not like that they [ __ ] once they
were done with your [ __ ] you were [ __ ]
yeah they're pretty much like why are
you even sitting around here so yeah
well they big up their mind early on
whether or not they gonna kill you
anyway yeah on the [ __ ] case you know
I mean that guy [ __ ] you gotta go and
now they did ask him before they
executed him they said hey anything else
you want to tell us like any more crimes
you want to confess to you but he
wouldn't yeah so it's possible that he
killed more than five or six people
because he did kind of hint that he
probably the night probably didn't do it
he probably didn't you know why had he
killed other ones he probably would have
started talking because that would have
bought him more time yeah a lot of them
do you kind of do that yeah
they'll even like make up [ __ ] or like I
said confess to [ __ ] they didn't do yeah
order to do that yourselves a live
lawyer they start asking for proof and
all your shits kind of be in a row about
where you were living at what time and
what what person it was that you killed
they know when you're lying you know I
mean if you don't lie about it they
usually find out within a few days but
if you got a bunch of good cases that
you know if you had 20 bodies out there
[ __ ] you could stretch that out probably
under 4 or 5 years of life yeah you
probably so I don't think I don't think
he I don't think he killed any more
probably not probably not but you know
that's that's more than enough yeah but
after he got executed like I said he was
kind of a big celebrity at the time
maybe though he's mostly forgotten
nowadays the media compared him to HH
Holmes although they did note that
obviously HH Holmes it seemed like his
motive was largely financial because he
did do like a lot of insurance fraud and
stuff that's actually how he started out
doing like insurance fraud before you go
back and see our HH Holmes show yeah I
don't think it was purely financial no
but it seemed like that was kind of a
whereas this guy seemed to just like
kill people for the [ __ ] yeah like
like a true serial killer
because he enjoyed it I guess I believed
in the case of HH Holmes he was a serial
rapist he lied to women he realized that
he could make a [ __ ] murder castle
with all his money and kill women
torture him rape him do whatever he
wanted with him and then sell their
skeletons as a medical stuff you know
yeah wasn't it yeah so he was every part
of yeah he was usually they say use
every part of the pig even the oink yeah
that's what he was doing same principle
because you couldn't you couldn't do
what HH Holmes did unless it was part of
your sexual orientation you know I'm
gonna it's a sex drive that [ __ ]
had some willpower it's not some just
some passing phase I mean yeah hold
he fantasized about that that's what
drove him he built the whole [ __ ]
thing and it wasn't really just all
about money I mean he wanted money to
build murder castles to go get more
girls that's what he was about
yeah and to have high status that [ __ ]
was a loser well like I said they they
tend to be they all tend to be yeah it
made me one serial killer that was like
a winner in any way shape or form you
can't you can't name one now the closest
thing to a serial killer winner would
have been Ted Bundy and that
[ __ ] would have sex with
decapitated heads now tell me if that's
a winner that's what I mean there's and
then you know and he had a heart no
that's what I mean you can't think of
one there isn't one no there isn't one
because like I said if they were
successful right they would to any place
sure they wouldn't be like that right
serial killer being a serial killer is
compensating for your weaknesses and
yeah if that's exactly what you know and
and you know I mean successful men don't
have those kind of weaknesses I mean
these two guys are [ __ ] scum yeah
exactly yeah all right so I think we've
probably got online for about these
nineteenth-century murders I hope you
guys are enjoying these kind of or
longer variety show type things that
we're doing for the month of October we
might do have some later on to it's just
whenever I feel like it but I just
thought it'd be neat to do like it's
entertainment for you people while
you're out on a road or what we're
[ __ ] and I'm going to sleep or clean
your house I mean we get contacted so
many people you know online or telling
us what it is they actually do when they
listen when they listen yeah so they
like them when they're longer yeah huge
female audience but we have male
audience too but it seems like it's
mostly women and they like this [ __ ] you
know yeah they like listening to
drunkenly rambling yeah it's kinda like
cross between a [ __ ] Howard Stern
Show and [ __ ] and [ __ ] art bell
but it's about [ __ ] paranormal serial
killers and you have we haven't done any
paranormal a while we actually got to
get back to but the requests have been
for series like I said most of their
props I get for true crime and you know
like I said we're probably gonna do true
crime next week yeah but then like the
Halloween show is gonna be scary stories
and yes Halloween lore
we've just covered so much of the
[ __ ] troop of the paranormal the big
paranormal cases we've covered them
already yeah that's true you know and
you know as much UFO stuff but man
there's so many other channels that are
really good at UFOs and a lot of its
like I find like some of them are
interesting but I find a lot of them
kind of say me yeah well there aren't
very many really good UFO cases that's
what I mean it's like there's only so
many there's there's only only so much
entertainment value can get about while
I was driving around a lonely highway at
night and then there was a light and I
lost three hours yeah and yeah I mean
you know a lot of them seem to be like
that that's creepy and everything but
it's like you know and I believe a lot
of these second military [ __ ] pilot
military sightings with the [ __ ]
fighter pilots and stuff you know I mean
just just do even the Navy's got to come
out good well it's gotta be some we've
seen I don't think they're all imagining
yeah well then when the Navy comes out
says yeah we see stuff if you see
something tell us yeah if you see
something say something
right that's what there's telling the
pilots now based on based on I laugh but
I would [ __ ] my pants if I saw a [ __ ]
alien some kind of extra
extraterrestrial craft some of those are
not all of them probably but I think
it's the living probe droids little
probe droids yeah we have so many good
handles of the show yeah the [ __ ]
whole gang and like what it what did I
say what was the first one that we said
how am I gonna remember
here's another [ __ ] yes Mac it's
another random [ __ ] one other
[ __ ] yeah say it was like
something that had like a really nice
like synergy to it we have a good idea
for a good topic go ahead and drop it in
a comment section
yeah it's up on patreon or Facebook our
patrons always have the first and first
choice on topics yeah that's there's
some of you big heavy rolling
[ __ ] at $20 a month whatever
show you why well figure it out might
take us a while to get work finished
goddamn money we work
is very hard I work I know you did
there's all kinds of good [ __ ] we can do
shows on that's what I mean well like I
said I have two or three years worth of
[ __ ] topics yeah and the order that I
do them in just kind of usually depends
on like what [ __ ] mood I'm in or or
requests or something like that yeah you
know what I mean because I just have so
much stuff and I don't even know if I'm
ever gonna get all of it
no because the new stuff of coop also uh
current events yeah I know the next same
cult [ __ ] that we did was really good
well and that just that new and I've had
like at least three or four different
listeners like send me a thing about
that [ __ ] serial killer they just
caught that's killed like 93 [ __ ]
people maybe we ought to do something
like that that's what I mean yeah he's
kind of like the Grim Sleeper but he's
like a different you know I mean okay
well but uh so we might do a show about
that day probably not this month because
I already have these the next two
planned out but maybe at the beginning
of November perhaps alright alright so
that will do it for episode 165 about
various serial killers from the old
timey days of the 19th century hope you
guys enjoyed it remember if you liked
the show like share subscribe on all
your social media and if you'd like to
financially support the show be very
much appreciated we have a patreon page
at 13 o'clock podcast whirring at our
blog 13 o'clock podcast wordpress.com
and there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account that we'll go to if you'd
like to give a one-time donation
remember these regular ass episodes
right here come out every Tuesday movie
retrospectives which is usually old
movies that comes out every Friday
matinee which is usually three new
movies or series or whatever we that
comes out every Sunday and if you're a
patron you get to see everything a day
early so that's like super exciting and
that will do it for this episode we will
see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]